Org
Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch. Ich war gerade auf dem Klo, ja jetzt, kurz vor 20 Sekunden,
bevor der Stream richtig angegangen ist, da habe ich die YouTube App aufgemacht. Und da ist mir
aufgefallen, dass die YouTube App die Zeit nun irgendwie falsch rumzählt. Habt ihr das auch?
Die zählen jetzt nicht mehr, die fangen jetzt nicht mehr von 0 an, sondern quasi von 7 und,
was weiß ich, wenn das Video 27 Minuten geht, dann fangen die an zu zählen von 27 Richtung 0.
Was haben die sich denn dabei wieder überlegt? Kannst du ändern? Wirklich,
aber warum ist das überhaupt ein Ding auf dem Desktop, ist das nicht?
Achso, das, okay, das wusste ich nicht.
Alles ist total bescheuert. Wer braucht das überhaupt?
Ganz Casual Noobs wieder. Bist du aus Versehen,
wahrscheinlich? Wahrscheinlich bin ich aus Versehen auf die Zeit gekommen.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein, Chat. Davon gehe ich mal aus, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Waschfinger, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Soll ich euch nochmal was sagen? Richtig, richtig Pepega-Time wieder gewesen bei mir.
Und zwar, kein normales Pepega-Emote, doch. Da sind sie ja genau richtig hier.
Zack, bevor ich weiter rede, New World, lass mich mal kurz checken, bevor ich weiter rede.
Nicht nice, lass mal kurz gucken. Ach ja, wird er immer besser.
Das letzte Mal hatte ich gesagt, wo war man das letzte Mal bei 70% der Spieler weggerannt?
Mittlerweile sind wir bei 85% der Spieler.
Läuft bei Amazon. Bezos freut sich bestimmt.
Die Zoomer sind schon längst abgesprungen bei so was.
Die haben Aufmerksamkeitsspanne von drei Sekunden.
Wenn du Zoomern irgendwelche Fakten erzählen willst,
dann musst du dabei noch Ausdruckstanz machen, dass sie das Video nicht ausschalten.
Sonst funktioniert das nicht. Das ist kein Witz.
Ach, das ist halt wieder geil. Ach ja, wie sieht es sein, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind. Ich wollte euch eigentlich was anderes erzählen, aber gucken wir doch mal.
Naja, auch nicht viel besser, würde ich sagen, oder?
Was hatte denn hier für Steam Charts?
Tatsächlich, da spielen sogar noch Leute, wer hätte das gedacht?
Lul. HD.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Kommen wir mal auf Steam Stats gucken.
Die Sache ist aber die. Ach, ich habe den Chat nicht eingeplant. Sekunde.
Der Chat fehlt, weil ich ein Video aufgenommen habe hier. Jetzt haben wir es.
Nice.
Hab ich vergessen. Was?
Einige Suchergebnisse können anstößig sein.
Warum genau?
Was ist daran? Also ja, das ist schon anders. Das Spiel an sich fand ich anstößig.
Es spielen tatsächlich gerade zumindest über Steam. Über Steam muss man sagen.
Über Steam spielen gerade quasi gleich viele Leute Battlefield 5 24 Stunden Peak wie Battlefield 2042.
Ja, kann man, kann man glaube ich so so rauslesen da.
Na gut, ich wollte euch eigentlich was anderes erzählen, nämlich richtig richtig pepega.
Was ich gemacht habe, als der neue Raspberry Pi rausgekommen ist.
Vor ein paar Wochen habt ihr mitgekriegt, habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht welche kaufe.
Und ich habe mir damals gedacht, ach nee, wozu?
Eigentlich habe ich überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck dafür. Also habe ich mir keinen gekauft.
So vor ein paar Tagen habe ich mir so gedacht, ach, ich könnte eigentlich mal die Kamera, die ich habe fürs Hoftor.
Dann könnte ich mal neu bauen mit einem, weil aktuell ist es ein Raspberry Pi Zero.
Da läuft kein.NET Gescheit drauf und irgendwie nichts. Die Zeros sind halt lahm as fuck und naja.
Ich habe mir gedacht, machste, machste dir doch einfach, mach das mal neu, mach das mal neu und gut ist.
Also richtig pepega gewesen. Hab rumgeguckt, wo gibt es Raspberry Pi Zeros?
Hab dann auch so ein paar Sachen gefunden, aber am Endeffekt habe ich vier Stück bestellt.
Bei einem Shop kann man zwei bestellen, bei dem anderen jeweils zwei.
Hab vier Stück bestellt und jetzt habe ich vier und ja, genau, und die Kamera hat ja Probleme gehabt.
Ich habe dann aber in der Zwischenzeit, wo ich auf die Lieferung gewartet habe von den Raspberry Pi Zero 2s,
habe ich die alte Hofkamera, Torkamera wieder gefixt. Die geht jetzt wieder.
Und jetzt habe ich vier Raspberry Pi Zero 2W hier und ich weiß nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Die sind einfach da. Hier, Leute.
Tüten ASMR. Magst du da? Danke für den Sub.
Tüten ASMR. Guckt. Nee, nicht Giveaway.
Was mich wundert, der hat, ich sehe es hier auch, es gibt mir auch Bilder an Mikro-USB, was ich ein bisschen durfte.
Ich verlose den doch nicht. Ich behalte den für irgendwann mal sinnvolle Sachen.
Wisst ihr, woran man erkennt, dass Raspberry Pi an sich nicht unter total unmenschlichen Bedingungen
und total billigst einfach nur hergestellt werden? Das merkt man daran, die stinken nicht.
Wenn ihr euch bei MaTechnik bestellt habt, bei AliExpress und umso billiger das war und umso mehr stinkt es.
Weiß ich, ob jemand schon mal die Erfahrung mit China-Chinesen-Elektronik gemacht hat?
Umso billiger ist es, umso mehr stinkt das Zeug.
Es ist wirklich so. Du musst es nicht bei AliExpress kaufen. Du kannst ja auch bei Amazon was billiges kaufen.
Umso billiger ist es, umso mehr stinkt es. Wisst ihr, was der schlimmste Stinker-Hardware war?
Wie komme ich jetzt überhaupt auf dieses Thema? Was auch immer.
Wisst ihr, was die schlimmste Stinker-Hardware war, die ich mir jemals gekauft habe?
Das war ein und wahrscheinlich, das ist jetzt nicht repräsentativ für den Hersteller oder so,
aber es war in dem Fall wirklich ganz, ganz grausam.
Das war ein SteelSeries-Mousepad.
Das habe ich mir mal gekauft bei so einem ganz großen, so einem SteelSeries XXL-Mousepad bei Amazon. Eigentlich gar nichts super billiges,
aber das hat so extrem abartig gerochen. Das habe ich zwei Wochen, jetzt ungelogen,
zwei Wochen auf dem Balkon hängen gehabt, bei Wind und Wetter, natürlich unterm Dach.
Das Problem ist bloß, das mag wohl die Kälte nicht und jetzt hat das Mousepad Wellen.
Hat sich nicht gelohnt, das zu kaufen. Das waren irgendwie 25 Euro oder so in den Sand gesetzt.
Naja. Ach ja, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Die Leute, die sich angemeldet haben hier mit DNS-Log.
Also die beste Idee, die beste Idee, fand ich immer noch, hatte der Typ, der gedacht hat, er nimmt das Nummernschild.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich fake. Aber allein schon die Idee finde ich geil.
Einfach mal durch die Stadt fahren damit und gucken, welche Kamerasoftware das Ganze versucht OCR zu erkennen
und dann hast du instant die halbe Stadt gehackermant. Eine richtig gute Idee.
Ja, das ist ursprünglich das Nummernschild mit SQL-Injection. Genau.
Schaust du, spielst du eigentlich ab und zu? Selten. Also Spielen gar nicht mehr. Schauen tue ich es ab und zu nochmal.
Das ist auch tatsächlich so. Ich schaue auch lieber eSport-Events als Fußball.
Das ist immer noch so. Und wenn mal irgendwelche großen CS-Majors sind, da war letztens irgendeins, ne?
Das habe ich aber tatsächlich nicht so verfolgt. Gucke ich auch immer mal wieder rein.
Ja, aber der letzte Teil ist auf jeden Fall immer noch so. Ich gucke immer noch lieber eSport als irgendwie Fußball oder so.
Da bin ich so ganz Zoomer. Oder gerade läuft es, ja.
Warum hat der Zoomer eigentlich ein Loch im Kopf? Erkennt ihr das? Oder ist das so ein krasser Undercut?
Ein Loch im Kopf passt ja auch ganz gut.
Ah, das ist eine Klatze hinten. Ist das modern?
Tja, was wollte ich eigentlich? Ich wollte doch am Anfang noch irgendwas sagen und sie haben mich jetzt komplett sidetracken lassen.
Wobei ich glaube, das war das mit den drei oder vier, mit den vier Raspberry Pies.
Wie fandet ihr eigentlich mein neues Video zu Log4j? Ich muss ja sagen, ich, übrigens angeblich YouTube denkt immer noch, ich sehe aus wie der Friseur, aber...
Was auch immer YouTube denkt, ja. Wie fandet ihr eigentlich mein letztes Video?
Ich bin nämlich überrascht über das Video, weil normalerweise kommen diese Themen mir immer wieder.
Weil normalerweise kommen diese Themen jetzt nicht schlecht an, aber die sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die Themen.
Also diese Videos sind jetzt normalerweise nicht so, dass die super viele Views haben.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass 25K super krass viele Views sind, aber sag mal mal so.
In einem Tag ist das schon, sag mal Standard.
Ähm, zumindest wenn man YouTube Analytics glaubt.
Bissle laut? Ach lang, muss ich grad sagen. Jetzt hat sich noch einer beschwert, die Videos werden immer zu leise.
Ja, aber diesmal, diesmal kommt wirklich gut an, kann man nix sagen.
Ja, also ich hab bisschen E-Mails gelesen bei mir, wie gesagt, ich bin ja froh, dass ich Urlaub hab, dass ich mich damit grad nicht beschäftigen muss.
Aber ja, ich hab mitbekommen, ich hab ein bisschen in meine E-Mails geguckt, auch ein bisschen in Teams geguckt.
Die schieben bei uns auf der Arbeit grad richtig Panik.
Natürlich, wie es so immer ist, gut, ich mein ich kenn die Details jetzt nicht, aber ich hab auch ein paar E-Mails geguckt,
die schieben bei uns auf der Arbeit grad richtig Panik, natürlich, wie es so immer ist, gut, ich mein ich kenn die Details jetzt nicht,
weil ich nicht dabei war und ich kann jetzt auch nicht so viel zu erzählen, aber die üblichen Verdächtigen sind wieder komplett planlos.
Wenn ich da schon, ich hab da ne Mail gesehen, da hat jemand geschrieben,
äh, so sinngemäß überraschenderweise hat sich jetzt rausgestellt, alle Anwendungen sind betroffen.
Unter anderem auch Anwendungen bei Dienstleistern, also nicht nur Anwendungen, die wir selbst entwickelt haben.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, hä, das war doch von Anfang an klar.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie auf die Idee kommt, dass das jetzt, warum sollte das so eine selbstentwickelte Anwendung betreffen?
Wie kommt man auf so eine glorreiche Idee?
Ja, also keine Ahnung, die üblichen planlosen Verdächtigen waren auch am Start.
Ich hätte jetzt ja noch mal rein posten können an die E-Mails, guck mal mein Video an,
hä, das, ne, aber das mach ich nicht.
Ähm, aber ansonsten sind jetzt alle, soweit ich das mitgekriegt hab, wild am Patchen,
beziehungsweise haben das größte, den größten Teil wohl alles schon gepatcht.
Die Sache ist ja auch die, dass je nach Infrastruktur man gar nicht so anfällig ist.
Hat man ordentliche ausgehende Firewall-Regeln, ist das meistens nicht so problematisch.
Ähm, wenn die Java-Dinger geschaltete Settings haben, passiert auch nichts.
Wenn die vielleicht kein Log4j verwenden, passiert auch nichts.
Und, ähm, wenn die neuere Version haben, passiert natürlich auch nichts.
Also, es kann durchaus sein, dass es gar nicht so viel Auswirkungen hat, wie man erst mal denkt,
aber potentiell ist halt erst mal alles, was in Java ist, davon betroffen.
Übrigens auch Desktop-Anwendungen, ja.
Also, wenn man Desktop-Anwendungen benutzt, die Java verwenden,
und man öffnet da drin vielleicht eine Datei mit einem manipulierten Dateiname,
und der Log das, dann ist auch instant am Arsch.
Aber wer verwendet Java auf dem Desktop?
Was gibt es Java auf dem Desktop schon?
Minecraft, ansonsten, was, fällt euch noch irgendwas ein?
Die JetBrains-IDEs, JetBrain-IDEs vielleicht.
Weiß nicht, ob die Log4j verwenden, keine Ahnung.
Gucken wir mal.
Okay, all IntelliJ-based Platt-IDEs not affected.
Na dann.
Dann ist ja alles gut.
Ja, den anderen Krempel verwende ich ja nicht.
Passt ja, hat sich ja alles erledigt, da ist das nicht so wild.
Ja, da habe ich in Raspberry Pi 3 aktuell dran.
Ja, wie gesagt, also das Video hat relativ viele, also hat ziemlich gute Views für so ein Technikvideo und insgesamt halt durchschnittliche Views,
aber das ist wirklich gut für so eine Sorte Video.
Mir tut immer noch der Hals weh, wenn du es genau wissen willst.
Ja, das Atlassian Zeug läuft alles mit Java, wobei ich nicht weiß, wie es dort betroffenermaßen aussieht, keine Ahnung.
Ist Ryra auch betroffen?
Die Weihnachtsbaum-Beleuchtung ist gefixt, ja.
Ja, bei Ruby Knalls, wenn irgendwie einer Gem-Version zurückzieht und sowas, gibt ja überall Probleme und teilweise echt simpelste Dinge,
wo ich mir denke, warum ist das immer vorher keinem aufgefallen.
Was aber auch wieder ein Vorteil ist für Open Source letztendlich, ne?
Es ist jetzt ja zum Glück mal irgendjemand aufgefallen.
Ein richtiges Lichterkettenmodell, ich benutze, das kommt darauf an, für was.
Also für den Weihnachtsbaum benutze ich was, was ein bisschen länger ist mit weniger LEDs.
BTF-Lightning-Store, ne wie heißen die Dinger?
Ich kann mir immer den Namen von diesem Kack-Shop nicht merken.
BTF-Lightning-Store, doch, doch, die meine ich.
Die Dinger hier habe ich.
Keine Toss-Musik, China-Chinesen, please.
Für Weihnachtsbaum habe ich die Dinger. Alter, haben wir hier vielleicht mal einen gescheiten...
Was ist das wieder für ein Shop, man?
Als hieß das Ding, ja, die hier.
GitHub Trends schon geschaut, Trends, können wir mal tatsächlich heute mal ein bisschen reingucken.
Also die hier habe ich für einen Weihnachtsbaum.
Ich hatte erst zwei Stück dran, also das sind 50 LEDs auf 5 Meter,
weil ich meinen um so einen Baum musst du schon ein bisschen was drum herumwickeln.
Thrinet X, danke für den Sub. Ich habe angefangen mit zwei Ketten ineinander gesteckt.
Das ist ja das schöne an adressierbaren LEDs, die kannst du beliebig oft verlängern,
solange du halt netzteilmäßig injectest zwischendurch.
Ich habe angefangen mit 10 Metern und dann sah das ganze bei mir so aus mit 10 Meter LEDs.
Zack, gepostet. So, man sieht 10 Meter haben nicht gereicht.
Hier unten LED, LED und ab hier war Schluss.
Also für einen normalgroßen Baum, der ist jetzt nicht riesig, der ist aber schon größer als das, was ich sonst habe,
reichen 10 Meter LEDs auch nur zwei Drittel.
So, und jetzt habe ich davon noch welche bestellt gehabt und habe die dran gemacht gestern.
Und ich habe jetzt noch eine Kette übrig, ich habe jetzt 15 Meter, 15 Meter, 15 Meter Kette und 150 LEDs.
Das Problem ist nur, bei 15 Metern Kette reicht es nicht, wenn du das Netzteil bzw. deinen Controller,
wobei die Controller schon, aber du darfst Strom nicht nur auf einer Seite anschließen.
Wenn du Strom nur auf einer Seite anschließt, dann hast du das Problem, dass die LEDs,
quasi hier siehst du ja, hier sind alle noch weiß, die werden dann gelb zu rot.
Also die LEDs und das Kabel haben über 10 Meter plus so viel Widerstand,
dass nicht mehr genug Spannung ankommt an den LEDs, die da hinten ankommen und dann werden sie zunehmend rot.
Warum werden sie rot, Chet? Ganz klar, weil blaues Licht mehr Energie braucht wie rotes Licht.
Deswegen funktioniert rotes Licht noch länger als blaues Licht.
Und deswegen ist rotes Licht auch das, was bei LEDs zuletzt ausgeht, wenn ihr die ausschaltet.
Wenn ihr mal so einen LED-Strip ausschaltet und mal ganz genau guckt, das letzte, was ihr seht,
meistens ist die rote LED, die noch nachleuchtet. So für, keine Ahnung, 200 Millisekunden oder so.
Ja, genau, und jetzt habe ich 15 Meter an meinem Weihnachtsbaum von diesen Dingern vorne dran,
WLED auf dem ESP32 und insgesamt, ich habe einen 5 Volt, 10 Ampere Netzteil dran
und ich habe Injected an beiden Seiten, also sprich, die haben jetzt hier kein scheiß Bild.
Ja, was zum, was, was, Moment, Moment, was, was wollen die uns hier erzählen?
Genauso, genauso habe ich es gemacht. Was auch immer, was auch immer das hier ist, keine Ahnung.
Ach so, die Injected bis zwei, genauso habe ich es gemacht, zwei, zwei Ketten ineinander gesteckt
und dann, nee, das stimmt nicht, so habe ich es nicht gemacht, ich habe drei Ketten ineinander gesteckt
und dann hier Injected, also 5 Volt, Power kommt hier vorne dran und hinten dran und dann funktioniert das.
Also, die kann ich empfehlen, die sind echt nicht schlecht.
Ja, und eine WLED gebaut haben wir schon oft genug im Stream.
Hey, ich bekomme mittlerweile Anfragen, Sekunde, Leute, das muss ich euch mal, was finde ich das jetzt?
Ich, ich gucke mal kurz, ich gucke mal kurz, ob ich die Mail finde.
Ich bekomme mittlerweile schon lustige Consulting-Anfragen per Mail.
Wartet mal, ich gucke mal, ob ich das finde, euch, das kann ich euch das mal vorlesen.
Das ist Battlefield-Sponsoring.
Stellenausschreibung.
Ja, und zwar mich hat jemand angeschrieben von, Namen sage ich jetzt nicht,
ähm, irgendeine Consulting-Firma, würde ich sagen, und die haben mir eine Mail geschrieben mit
Hallo Max, wir möchten in unserem Unternehmen ein Entwicklerteam aufbauen.
Habe hierfür schon einen Textentwurf gemacht, wäre richtig nice, wenn du mal über die Stellenanzeige drüber liest.
Ich werde schon Consulted zu Stellenanzeigen.
Ich habe ihm dann auch geantwortet, so ganz kurz, so dass ich das eigentlich ganz nice finde.
Und, äh, wenn er noch mehr Details haben will, habe ich ein bisschen umschrieben, zurückgeschrieben,
dann lässt sich da sicherlich, äh, was gegen, äh, quasi, äh, Honorar machen, ja, aber ist er nicht drauf eingestiegen.
Ich habe im Kleinen versucht, das zu verkaufen als Dienstleistung, aber hat nicht funktioniert.
Aber ich meine eigentlich, ohne Scheiß, die suchen aktuell so viele IT-Leute,
und ich sehe so viele einfach nur schlechte Stellenanzeigen, die vielleicht Leute in der Not jetzt ansprechen oder so.
Aber nicht quasi so, wenn man, wenn man, sag mal mal, um wirklich gute Leute wirbt mit mehreren Unternehmen,
dann sind das meistens nicht die Stellenanzeigen, die einen so on, on, on top rauskommen lassen.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das würde sich auszahlen, würde mir, würde, würde jemand,
nicht, muss ja nicht unbedingt ich machen, ja, aber würde jemand mal von seinem hohen Rost runterkommen
und vielleicht auch mal bei ihnen, äh, die Techniker fragen und so nach dem Motto,
hier, was meinst du, würde dich das ansprechen.
Also ich, ich gehe davon aus, die Stellenanzeigen könnten um ein Vielfaches besser sein,
wenn Human Resources oder wie auch immer, wenn die Personalabteilung,
mal Leute, die sie schon haben in ihrem Unternehmen, dazu fragt, wie findet ihr unsere Stellenanzeige.
Das wäre zu einfach, ne?
PoE-Tools sind ja wahr.
Oh shit, ich habe auch noch PoE-Tools installiert. MonkaS.
Look for J incoming.
Wie ist der Kram? Next? Da ist es, weg.
Ah, das ist bestimmt Java, oder?
Excellent, next. GitHub.
Ach ne, das ist JavaScript.
Okay, wir sind safe. Chat, wir sind safe.
Das ist JavaScript. Das heißt, das ist eine Elektron-Anwendung.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was ich schlimmer finde.
Eine Java-Anwendung mit lock4j-Bug oder eine Elektron-Anwendung?
Ansonsten, ich habe Java ja nicht mehr installiert.
Elektron mit lock4j-Rapport.
Wie soll denn das ausschauen?
Das wäre ja mal richtig brutal.
Dann bräuchte es eine Chrome-Runtime, du bräuchte es ein Node.js und du bräuchte eine Java-Runtime.
Machst du was zu Dortmaui, wenn es rauskommt?
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe für Dortmaui keine großen Hoffnungen.
Erstens fehlt mir der Linux-Support.
Und außerdem alles, was ich von Xamarin gesehen habe, ist das mega umständlich gewesen.
Dass ich damit auch keine Apps erstellen will.
Und das ist ja im Prinzip Xamarin Next quasi.
Was könnten noch... Passive Building?
Nee, Passive Building habe ich glaube ich nimmer.
Passive Building ist bestimmt Java.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Euer Ticket-System läuft auf Java.
Na dann würde ich gleich mal ein Ticket erstellen.
LDAP-Doppelpunkt-Slash-Slash.
Und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ne, JDNI-Doppelpunkt-LDAP-Doppelpunkt-Slash-Slash.
Gleich mal gucken.
Machst du den Advent of Code?
Ne, ich weiß was es ist.
Weil ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht so genau was es ist.
Aber ich weiß, dass es existiert.
Aber ich mich noch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Dem Problem mache ich da auch nicht mit.
Was ist das eigentlich genau?
Gucken wir jetzt mal.
Kommen wir gleich.
Ich lese jetzt noch mal schnell die Fragen fertig.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein großes Problem.
Das hast du ja bei vielen IoT-Geschichten.
Auch die mit Bluetooth-Lücken und WLAN-Lücken und sowas in der Richtung.
Ja gut, Kotlin hat im Prinzip das gleiche Problem.
Also, ja, IoT-Geräte sind tatsächlich ein Problem.
Hast du bei vielen anderen angreifbaren IoT-Geschichten, die nicht gepatcht werden auch.
Ja, das ist wirklich ziemlich kacke.
Ja, aber die verwenden wahrscheinlich kein Log4j.
Wann geht das Super-Powergas-Minecraft-Server online?
Den muss ich erst abschalten, weil Hacker-Mans.
Ach, stimmt, du hast recht, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Dafür braucht man mal früher ja auch.
Also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, bei den alten iDRACs.
Nee, wie heißen die?
Nee, RSA heißen die Dinger von IBM.
Bei den alten RSAs von IBM, da hatten wir nach einer Zeit das Problem.
Wir benutzen ja auf der Arbeit zum größten Teil Linux, auch auf den kleinen Rechnern.
Also, die Leute, die sich halt um wichtige Systeme kümmern, sagen wir mal.
Da hatten wir das Problem, dass wir extra dafür Windows-Kisten gebraucht haben,
mit einer alten Java-Version, Plugins und Internet Explorer 6 oder was das war,
dass man überhaupt auf die alten RSAs noch Remote drauf gekommen ist.
Abenteuerliche Geschichte.
Ja, gut, der praktische Teil ist dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen Overkill.
Geht die Weihnachtslaune? Ja, ja, wie gesagt, geht.
Na, dann ist gut.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, es ist so.
Da wäre ich mir gar nicht so sicher, dass es, also,
ich würde nicht meine Hand dafür in den Toaster legen,
sagen wir mal ins Feuer legen, dass es keinen Toaster gibt,
der mit Java verwendet und nicht Log von J angreifbar ist.
Ich glaube, danach richtet sich da keiner.
Dann hätten die ganzen Hacker-Mans das jetzt ausnutzen können in der Zwischenzeit.
GitHub Trends können wir uns gleich anschauen.
Danke für den Zapp.
Wie gesagt, ich habe Urlaub seit, seit wann habe ich denn Urlaub?
Seit einem Monat? Nee.
Hier seit, sagen wir mal, fast einem Monat habe ich Urlaub.
Muss man sich überlegen, so lange schon?
Alter, so lang kommt mir gar nicht so lang vor.
Ich denke, ich habe erst angefangen.
Dabei ist das ja schon in eins, zwei, drei Wochen wieder oben.
Anzeige ist raus.
Soll das?
Ja, ist es im Endeffekt.
Safari auf dem Desktop auch, aber vielleicht ein bisschen weniger.
Das Schlimmste ist Safari iOS.
Safari iOS ist im Prinzip der neue Internet Explorer.
Ich meine, es ist nicht ganz so krass wie damals der Internet Explorer.
Aber ähnliche Dinge.
Sie machen auch so ein paar eigene Sachen.
Dafür machen sie Standardsachen, obwohl sie sagen,
sie unter den bestützenden Standard machen sie wiederum nicht.
Und sie sind halt hoffnungslos hinten dran, was aktuelle Webgeschichten angeht.
Und einiges davon will Apple halt auch nicht, weil sie genau wüssten,
wenn sie es machen, ist das quasi Konkurrenz zum App Store.
Oder könnte Konkurrenz zum App Store gehen.
Wieso die Log4j Lücke so gefährlich?
Na ja, weil es viele Software gibt, die auf Java basiert,
auch gerade im Enterprise Business Umfeld.
Und du es total einfach ausnutzen kannst.
Also sollte ich jemals als Consultant arbeiten, dann ist ja
unter der Geringverdiener Grenze hier geht natürlich nichts.
Entry-Level-Blockchain, das klingt massiv feifett, aber agil muss es auch sein.
Big Data und AI vielleicht noch irgendwie einbauen.
Ich habe den Chat vielleicht irgendwann auch mal.
Man könnte einfach auch mehr.NET Backends verwenden,
anstatt irgendwelches komisches JavaScript Zeug da.
Wobei JavaScript Backends tatsächlich ganz nice sind.
Ich habe das persönlich noch nie gemacht, aber ich glaube,
wenn man wirklich einen Web-Service anbietet, den End-User benutzen,
dann ist so ein JavaScript Backend ganz gut,
weil du kannst Server-Side-Rendering machen
für relativ viele Frontend-Frameworks mittlerweile.
Und ich glaube, das funktioniert nur gescheit mit einem Node.js Backend.
Und Server-Side-Rendering ist natürlich eine coole Geschichte,
auch weil die Seite schneller ausgeliefert wird,
bzw. weil die Seite schneller erscheint beim Client.
Also man macht quasi Server-Side-Rendering
und danach macht man halt weiter kleinzeitig.
Das ist das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Du hast kleinzeitig in der Anwendung laufen
und der End-User sieht halt schneller.
Ja, Next.js ist voll beliebt, ja.
Aber es ist nicht nur Next.js, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Sachen.
JavaScript ist auch nur so schnell,
weil die Google-Leute um V8 extrem große Gehirne haben.
Ich habe mal einen Konferenztalk gesehen
von einem, der an Chrome arbeitet und optimiert.
Die machen da vielleicht einen Scheiß drin, dass das schneller wird.
Meine Güte.
Zum Beispiel wusstet ihr, dass wenn Chrome JavaScript ausführt,
der das parallel ist nicht das richtige Wort,
dass der das zweigleisig ausführt.
Also sprich, damit die Webseite losläuft,
interpretiert er das erstmal
und dann versucht er irgendwie,
den heißen Pfad der Anwendung rauszufinden
und den dann quasi noch nebenbei zu optimieren,
dass wenn du wieder dann da reinspringst,
dass das nächste Mal ausführt, es deutlich schneller geht.
Dann haben die auch so komische Predictions drin,
wie lange laufen, schleifen
und kann man das nicht im Vorfeld quasi entrollen,
ich weiß nicht, wie das richtige Wort ist,
dass die Schleife erst gar nicht laufen muss
und so was.
Also ganz ehrlich,
V8 ist sowas von Big Brain.
Ich glaube, da gibt es nicht viele auf der Welt, die da durchblicken.
Sowas in der Richtung, ja, machen die.
Also gerade V8 ist wirklich Next Level Five Head.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die genau machen.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Also ich weiß ja nicht, was RPG ist.
Ist das sowas wie Rex oder so?
Das ist aber die richtig schleiße Oldschool-Geschichte.
Bei Cobol hast du zumindest kein Problem,
was Log4j angeht.
Ja, Cobol kenne ich mich aus.
Hey, ich glaube, ungelogen,
ich kann mehr als 99 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung Cobol
allein schon dadurch,
dass wir uns das einmal drei Stunden im Stream angeguckt haben.
Ich könnte eigentlich auf meinen Lebenslauf
Cobol-Erfahrungen schreiben jetzt.
Ich habe bestimmt mehr Cobol-Erfahrung als die meisten Menschen
je gehabt haben und haben werden
durch diese drei Stunden im Stream.
Doch geht.
Es gibt Cobol zu Java-Compiler,
das verwenden wir auf der Arbeit auch,
weil keiner will mehr Oldschool-Cobol-Zeug laufen lassen.
Wir konvertieren unser Cobol in Java.
Das ist eigentlich richtig Mocker-S,
wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Ja, das waren wir auch.
Cobol zu Java.
So, was haben wir denn hier auf?
Wire-Spomben, die kann ich...
Was soll ich gucken?
GitHub-Trends und Advent of Code.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, keinen Schimmer.
Ach, das sind die Türchen, oder was?
Oh, das ist Five Head Programming Challenge-Kram, oder?
Oh, Massive.
Da musst du High IQ haben.
Den habe ich heute Abend nicht mehr.
Go-Brain.
Kann man da am Ende auch was gewinnen?
Oder ist das rein Just For...
Wer hat den längsten?
Was auch vollkommen okay ist.
Just For E-Penis.
Ich mache jetzt nicht die erste.
Ich mache jetzt bestimmt keinen Broggastells.
So, aber GitHub-Trends soll ich mal schnell gucken.
Können wir mal ganz schnell machen, so zwei Minuten lang.
Zeit mal her.
Danach gucken wir, ob uns YouTube irgendwas...
Na gut, das ist klar, dass der Kram trendet.
Log for Shell-Tester, Log for Shell...
Im Prinzip trendet alles, was irgendwie damit zu tun hat.
Den kennen wir.
Den haben wir uns letztens im Stream angeguckt.
Was das sein soll, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Check ich nicht.
Irgendwelche Rechnung generieren.
Hä, was?
Zift.
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Ist das eine Eule?
Soll das eine Eule sein?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Okay.
Log for...
To scan, okay.
Log for J, Log for J.
Dann haben wir irgendwie...
Face Restoration.
Was auch immer.
Alter, die haben so viel Big Brain Zeug mittlerweile.
Die haben so viel Big Brain Learning am Start.
Auf GitHub, das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Aha.
Face Restoration.
Dass es sich alles gibt, ja.
Dann könnte ich ein Foto von meinem Opa mal reinwerfen und mal gucken, wie er früher ausgesehen hat.
Okay, also GitHub Trends bestehen im Prinzip heute quasi exklusiv aus Log for J, hä?
Tasks.
Tasks einfach Tasks nicht sagen.
Ah, no description, alles klar.
Ah, gekommen.
Alles klar, was es macht, oder?
Stage 0.
Ah, das ist ein russischer, ein russischer HTML Kurs oder sowas?
Das ist ein russischer HTML CSS Kurs.
Weird Champ.
Lisp.
Wer ist denn so masochistisch heutzutage und macht was in Lisp?
Wollt ihr mal Weird Champ Source Codes sehen?
Einfach viele Klammern, dann ist es Lisp.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Obvious, obvious.
Ja, Lisp, genauso wie Erlang und sowas, die haben einfach immer gerne Klammern.
Subway.
Sandwich Attacks.
Ich weiß nicht, was eine Sandwich Attack ist, aber das klingt erstmal unanständig.
Okay, aber die aktuellen GitHub Trends sind eindeutig geprägt von Log for J.
Anders kann man das nicht sagen.
So, schauen wir mal kurz in YouTube rein, ob die uns irgendwas Sinnvolles empfehlen,
was wir heute Abend gucken könnten.
Next-Gen Missile Tracking, nee.
Wir gucken uns mal, da habe ich vorher angefangen zu gucken,
wir gucken uns mal das 200-Stunden-Fazit-Video vom Lost an,
was er irgendwie vor ein paar Tagen hochgeladen hat.
Ich habe nur den Anfang geguckt und habe auch schon Kommentar dagelassen,
weil der Anfang ist lustig.
Lost erklärt uns Versionsverwaltung, dass ich das nochmal erleben darf.
Was ich witzig finde, dass es sich mittlerweile auch schon mal Leuten,
die mit so Technik nicht viel am Hut haben, herumgesprochen hat,
was Branches sind bei einer Entwicklung und sonst was.
Auch wenn ich glaube, das grundlegende System noch nicht ganz umrissen hat,
ist schon mal cool, dass es sich verbreitet.
Was verdient ein Chemikant?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Beruf sich Chemikant nennt.
Müsste das nicht korrekterweise, ganz modern,
was verdienen Chemikantinnen heißen?
Nicht, dass die Diversity-Anzeige demnächst raus ist.
Inzidenzen, irony, please, keine Corona-News jetzt.
Spannendes, der Assassin's-Tea-Pod, alles klar.
Das Chemikant ist der Praktikant.
Da fällt mir ein ultraschlechter Pains-Champ-Witz ein.
Was ist blau und steht am Kopierer?
Der Praktikant.
Das ist so schlecht.
Jetzt wusste ich, dass du auch was geschrieben hast mit dem Wort.
Das ist extrem Pains-Champ-Witz.
Not Sponsored, VPN.
Übrigens, ich fühle mich sehr geehrt, muss ich sagen.
Wenn man in die Community-Posts guckt,
hat man ein Video geschert.
Die Empfehlungen von YouTube sind heute nicht so wahnsinnig spannend.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, das zu machen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Doch.
Das würde bestimmt funktionieren.
Ist Chatterino nicht Java?
Singletons, das fängt schon an. Oh ne, das ist C++! Ist ja noch schlimmer! Wer um alles
in der Welt macht denn eine Cross-Platform-Desktop-Anwendung für Twitch? Ist das wenigstens cute oder was
ist das? Auf was passiert das Moment, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken. Auf was genau
passiert Chatterino? Das ist gar nicht, wo ich da widgets. Ja okay, okay, in Ordnung, in Ordnung,
in Ordnung. Es ist eine cute Anwendung. Es ist zwar immer noch extrem abartig, dass das C++ ist,
aber warum nicht? Warum nicht? Ist so in Ordnung, in Ordnung. Pigeon ist auch C++,
wahrscheinlich. Das ist so alt, das ist wahrscheinlich. Nee, warte mal, ist Pigeon nicht
eines der ersten Python-Dinger gewesen? Nee, das war was anderes. Aber scheiße, das ist auch
C++, ja. Wahrscheinlich. Alter, CMake, so ein, also. Alter, C++, hör mal plus auf. Ist das Lisp
oder was? Warum sieht das so klammerig aus? Es gibt Sachen, die will man eigentlich gar nicht
so genau wissen. Du willst es nicht wissen. Wir haben uns gefragt, ob Chatterino nicht Java ist
und anfällig für Log4j wäre. Aber es ist anscheinend C++. Aber ich bilde, ist das das
Original Chatterino dann Java? Ich, wie gesagt, ich bilde mir ein, aber irgendwie, ich hatte es im
Hinterkopf, dass das Java ist. Meistens kann ich mir sowas ganz gut merken. Aber was ist denn
Chatterino 1, wenn das Chatterino 2 ist? Na gut, ist ja auch egal. Vielleicht war das nicht
Chatterino, sondern irgendwas anderes, was ich mal ausprobiert hatte, was für Twitch Chat auf
Java-Basis ist. Das ist natürlich komplett fatal dann. Wird das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Sind die überhaupt auf GitHub oder sind die immer noch auf irgendeinem komischen Repo Server,
wo kein Mensch checkt, wie es funktioniert? Ah, die sind auf Bitbucket sind die. Das verwendet
tatsächlich jemand. Okay. KeepI'mFreedom.org wird ja immer schlimmer, wo die sich rumtreiben.
Aber da wird immer noch regelmäßig committed hier. Chatty ist Java-Basis. Das kann sein,
dass ich das meine. Leute, so eine hässliche Bar, ist das eine Swing-Anwendung? Java-Kenner
unter uns hier. So ein ekliges Fenster, das muss bestimmt eine Swing-Anwendung sein. Oder? Ja,
guckt euch das mal an. Das ist bestimmt eine Swing-Anwendung. Wie heißt denn das
neue? Swing ist ja out. Wie hieß denn das? JavaFX heißt das neue. Genau, JavaFX. Ich
habe weder das eine noch das andere verwendet. Woran erkennt man, dass das Swing ist? Erstmal
kurz forkt. Warum forken die? Man weiß es nicht. Hat die Log4j betroffen? Ja, anscheinend
nicht. Okay, dann ist alles gut. JavaGui ist ein richtiger Painz-Champ, ja. So, gucken
wir mal. Aber was haben wir denn eigentlich noch für Videos von Sonntag offen? Da waren
bestimmt noch ein paar spannende Dinger dabei. Ich habe zu viele Fenster. Wie influenz ich
an Shine? Wer ist überhaupt Shine? Keine Ahnung. Wird das noch übrig? Noch das da?
Das hat der Chat gesagt. Sollte ich mir irgendwann mal angucken? Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das
wirklich lohnt. Battlefield Soundtrack? Top. Ah, two is binding. Das lohnt sich nicht.
League out of three? Genau. Wir gucken mal das Video vom Lost. Das wollte ich eh fertig
gucken. Und mal gucken, ob ihr die Sachen so sieht, wie ich auch da vor zwei Wochen Video
drüber gemacht habe. Gucken wir mal. L.O.S.T. Sagt er am Anfang irgendwann. Schau Linus
das Video bitte. Wie das da? Aber das ist doch, das ist, ich glaube das nicht, dass
das sonderlich, sonderlich spannend ist. Vor allem neunundzwanzig Minuten, mann. Trying
to do simple things. Okay, komm. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich verwende Linus selbst
jetzt ja schon insgesamt seit 2005 oder so. Regelmäßig. Das ist quasi 15 Jahre Linux.
15, 16 Jahre Linux Erfahrung. Und ich hab auch keine Ahnung oftmals, was ich da eigentlich
mache. Lass uns mal vor ne Prediction machen. Würde der Wupplos alle Aufgaben darin auf
Anhieb schaffen? Ja, kommen da dann Aufgaben drin vor? Oder ist das so ein Video, wo er
im Prinzip seine Unterhosen im Store bewerben kann? Ja, wir können ne Prediction machen.
Mods, Mods, wir machen mal ne Prediction. Schafft der Max die Aufgaben auch alle? Oder
würde der Max die Aufgaben auch schaffen? Ohne jetzt irgendwie großartig nachzugucken
und das Video zu gucken. Aber mal gucken, also kann durchaus sein, also mit so normalem
Desktop Zeug hab ich keine Ahnung. Warum, warum, warum macht man das eigentlich? Warum
sollte man Linux daily driven lassen auf einer Gaming Maschine? Das ist ja allein schon das
erste Problem. Man könnte sich Linux in ne VM packen auf seiner krassen Gaming Maschine,
gamen unter Windows und alles unter Linux machen, wofür Linux gut geeignet ist. Egal,
egal, es geht ja um die Challenge. So, zeig her. Mal gucken, was wir für ne Distribution
verwenden. Ah, yes, nice sellout. Xdanklite, Dankeschön für den Zap.
Ah, ok, hat PlayOnLinux benutzt, um Notepad++ zu installieren.
Ja gut, sag mal mal so, Wim ist sicherlich nicht jedermanns Sache, aber da ist doch bestimmt
irgendeinen G-Edit oder sowas standardmäßig drauf, was du doch ganz gut mit Notepad++
vergleichen kannst. Egal. Bitte nicht, Teams. Ja ok, ich hör auf.
Das ist doch fake, oder? Ich mein, die verdienen doch Geld damit. Die haben doch bestimmt
noch nebenbei nen Rechner mit Windows, wo alles eingerichtet ist, was so funktioniert,
wenn wirklich jetzt mal einer arbeiten muss, bzw. im Zweifelsfall, die haben ja auch bestimmt
irgendwelche Clients, wenn da da einer anruft und sagt, keine Ahnung, wir haben hier super
dringendes Sponsoring, oder was auch immer, 100 pro.
Ah, hier sind die Challenges. Ok, ok, ok. Moment. Also, Challenge, you must surmount.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet, so wahrscheinlich was wie überwinden oder sowas.
Ok, cut, paste the file from Wontail. Gut, das ist easy. Ich würd sogar das drive mounten
über Kommandozeile. Digitally signed PDF. Ok, da müsste ich mir BGP irgendwelche Dinger
durchlesen, das wüsste ich so aus dem Stegreif wahrscheinlich nicht. Export a chart from
Excel. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich hinbekommen, auch wenn ihr ja wisst, ich verwende keine
Office Anwendung, aber so Kalk anschmeißen und einen Chart exportieren, als Picture krieg
ich noch gebacken. So, add a new font. Auch das ist tatsächlich erstaunlich schwierig,
wenn er nicht im Package Manager drin ist. Dann muss man sich eine font config lokal
anlegen und den font da rein kopieren. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, dass der font im
Package Manager verfügbar ist, dann ist es easy. Print Worddoc. Das steht und fällt damit,
ob der Drucker gut unterstützt wird oder nicht. Ich würd mal davon ausgehen, das ist
ein halbwegs moderner Laserding-Drucker mit vielleicht Postscript oder sonst was. Dann
ist die Chance wahrscheinlich recht easy, dass es einfach funktioniert. Compress and send
all files on the drive. Das ist easy. Ta xfz. Ta xfzv. Ne, warte mal. Das ist Extracten,
was ich erzählen hab, nicht compressen. Ta minus c farts xfv. Irgendwie so. Krieg ich
aber auch relativ schnell raus. Take Screenshot. Ja gut, nur um passendes Screenshot-Tool installieren
und gut ist. Make a shortcut. Ich kann einen Link machen im Terminal, wenn das als Shortcut
durchgeht. Connect a network share. Das kann erstaunlich kompliziert sein, aber würde
ich auch über die Kommandozeile machen. Das weiß ich mittlerweile zum größten Zeit aus
dem Kopf, wie das geht. Aber Samba Shares connecten über das Netzwerk, also über Kommandozeile
kann erstaunlich kompliziert sein. Discord-App Open on Startup. Gut, Open on Startup hängt
davon ab, was es für ein Desktop-Environment ist. Watch 4K-Content. Gut, das ist kein Ding.
Einfach YouTube auf 4K schalten. Aber HDR-Content, wenn das... Ach nee, Moment, HDR. Es geht
nicht um Kopiergeschütz, nein. HDR-Content. Okay, da müsste ich passen, wenn das nicht
standardmäßig out of the box funktioniert, müsste ich gucken, müsste ich googeln, ob
das an irgendwelchen Grafikkartentreibern, Window-Managern, X- und Browser-Kombinationen
liegt. Vielleicht hat man auch Passion, es funktioniert nicht richtig. Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, wie sie sich anstellen. Easy.
Das hat doch einfach noch kopiert, oder? Der hat das ausgeführt, während es noch kopiert
hat, oder? Oder was war das jetzt eben?
Also eins können wir alle noch von Linus lernen, die Sellout-Überleitung, bzw. das sind ja nicht
mal geplante Überleitung, die kommen bei dem einfach mittlerweile so als Gedanke und gehen
rein, sind vorkommst, w Report.
Ich bin immer noch wütend darüber, seit 7-8 Jahren, als ich meinen MacOS Daily Driver-Challenge gemacht habe.
Die VLC wird nicht mehr geöffnet.
Jetzt bin ich ein wenig befürchtet, irgendetwas zu fassen.
Nautilist reportiert eine völlig andere Sache.
Okay.
Das File ist hier.
Und für irgendeine Grundlage...
...launcet die VLC jetzt.
Hat es nur so lange gedauert, um die Bewegungsoperation zu verhindern?
Es hat gedauert!
Ich halte ein kleiner File.
Ich versuche, TeamViewer.txt zu installieren.
Ich halte...
...gepastet.
Erfolg!
Challenge 2.
Digitale Bezeichnung des PDFs.
Ich habe keine speziellen PDF-Reader installiert.
Gut, das würde ich auch erwarten, dass mittlerweile... ist das Manjaro, was er hat?
Das sieht vom Grafik-Theme so Manjaro-grün aus.
Ich checke aber noch nicht, was das für eine Desktop-Umgebung ist.
Was hat das für eine Desktop-Umgebung? Was ist denn das?
Ist das Mate oder sowas?
KDE?
Okay, kann sein. KDE habe ich ehrlich gesagt seit 8 Jahren nicht mehr...
...gesehen bei mir auf dem Rechner.
Ach Moment, das habe ich komplett falsch verstanden.
Mit signieren meinen die unterschreiben?
Ich habe gedacht...
...BGP signieren nach dem Motto, ich bin auch der Versender und so.
Was meinen die jetzt mit signieren?
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte keine Ahnung, wie ich in einem PDF-Reader unter Linux...
...irgendwie eine Unterschrift von mir bekommen würde.
Kein Schimmer.
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Und die meisten Dinger, da muss sagen, okay, ich gebe zu, es ist keine Ausrede...
...das zu sagen, dass man das eigentlich nicht macht.
Ich hasse sowas normalerweise.
Wenn irgendwie einer sagt, wie geht das?
Und die Antwort ist dann, ja, das macht man doch eigentlich gar nicht.
Deswegen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es geht, gebe ich zu.
Aber es ist glaube ich auch relativ selten, dass du das in der Praxis machen musst.
Weil alles, was ich bisher unterschreiben musste, die letzten, was weiß ich, 5 Jahre...
...sei es jetzt irgendwelche NDAs oder irgendwelche Sponsoring-Geschichten...
...oder irgendwelche Abmachungen, irgendwas, was ich...
...sag mal, was man mit YouTube zu tun hat und was ich digital unterschreiben musste...
...das habe ich immer über einen Online-Service unterschrieben...
...und nicht irgendwelche PDFs signiert und zurückgeschickt.
LollofLoll hat Prime Gaming-Subscribed.
Dankeschön für den huge...
...prime...
...sumscrimer...
...pog.
Ja, in Deutschland brauchst du einen Fax.
Wobei, ich habe heute meinem Steuerberater zum ersten Mal rein digital...
...meine Sachen geschickt.
Ich habe einfach online einen Drive, also was, einen Ordner angelegt...
...habe ihm das dann geshared für seinen User...
...und habe mein Zeug hochgeladen.
Habe ihm eine Mail geschrieben, ob er seine Sachen hochgeladen hat.
Habe ihm eine Mail geschrieben, ob er es öffnen kann.
Und siehe da, es funktioniert alles.
Trite1337, danke für den Sub.
Tja.
Das würde ich auch nicht checken.
Wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Wenn ich keine Ahnung hätte, wie das funktioniert...
...ich würde mir einen Online-Service suchen, wo ich meinen PDF hochladen kann...
...dort signieren und dann wieder runterladen.
Gibt es bestimmt.
Die das hier Schritt für Schritt sagen.
Weil, wie das funktioniert mit den Linken...
...ich hätte absolut keinen Schimmer.
Ich weiß, wenn es einfach nur darum geht...
...wenn es einfach nur darum geht, äh, deine Unterschrift hinzukriegen...
...dann wäre es einfach...
...dann hätte ich mir das gescreenshotted...
...hätte das in irgendeinem Bildbearbeitungsprogramm aufgemacht...
...hätte meine Unterschrift drauf kopiert und hätte ausgedruckt.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht die Challenge.
Setge?
Ah nee, Sejda, ich habe Setge verstanden.
Sejge.
Hört sich fast wirklich so an.
Setge.
Das ist bestimmt...
Leute, werden das eine Elektron-Anwendung?
Sejja PDF, das ist bestimmt eine Elektron-Anwendung.
Ist auf GitHub?
Nee.
Java!
Es ist Java, Leute!
Passend zur aktuellen Geschichte.
Oh, die benutzen keinen Log4j.
Sie haben den Log4j 2014 rausgeschmissen.
Naja, okay.
Warte mal.
Das ist...
So ist das aber mit Signature nicht gedacht.
Eine Signature ist deine Unterschrift.
Die kannst du dir einfach nachmachen.
Die könntest du höchstens malen.
Aber das ist ja dann...
...ne, egal.
Setge.
Let me just verify that that worked.
Let's get out of here.
I don't need PDF-Mod.
PDF to sign.
Ich denke mal, ungefähr so lange hätte ich dafür auch gebraucht.
In dem Dreh.
Oh je.
Archvicky!
Archvicky, jetzt ist vorbei.
Ich glaube, die wissen nicht so genau, was die eigentlich wollen.
Wollen die einfach eine Unterschrift drunter haben?
Oder soll das digital signiert werden?
Signiert werden? Also das ist jetzt zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, was die da machen.
Let's encrypt.
Oh, or we can use the mkcert tool.
Hoho.
Da hat sich Ninos aber was ausgesucht.
Das wird abartig jetzt.
Yes, I know, Andy.
Das wird abartig.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
What commands?
Vergiss es.
Alright.
It's clear that this is a thing that you can do.
And it's something that I could figure out if I had another half an hour, an hour.
But unfortunately, it's not something that is quick or easy.
Ne, das, was er machen will, ist nicht easy.
Aber eine Unterschrift drauf kopieren ist schon easy, je nachdem, was die wollen.
I should have bailed a couple of minutes ago and switched over to my VM.
I failed challenge number two.
Export a chart from VXL.
Right click, save as a picture.
Ja gut, das ist easy.
Ne, in Kalk öffnen und...
Also das würde ich auch gebacken kriegen, denke ich mal.
Und das, obwohl ich nie...
This has got to be the chart we're trying to right click, export as image.
Did that work?
I've never done this before.
I wasn't even fully aware that was a thing.
Ich auch nicht.
Looks like it worked.
It has a transparent background.
But doesn't matter, I don't think.
So this black background is not...
Oh nein, Bots am Start.
Alles löschen, bannen Mods.
Black background is just an image.
Oh yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Here we go, here we go, here we go, okay.
You just have to find exactly the right spot.
Mod check, Mod check.
Hey, why is the name system volume information?
Weil das das Label ist.
System volume information, okay.
Ach ne, ne, ach das.
System volume information, ist das nicht irgendein NTFS-Ding?
Oder irgendein Windows-Ding?
I got it.
It's not quite right.
You can see it's actually missing the borders on the right and bottom.
But everything else here looks fine.
Call him out of W.
Out of new font.
Oh, Leute.
Das ist, je nachdem, was sie machen sollen, gar nicht...
Okay, wenn man natürlich GUI-Zeug hat, wo man reinträgt und droppen kann, ist es einfach.
Falls es geht.
Aber ich sag euch, Font-Config von Hand ist nicht so easy.
Wenn es im Package Manager ist, ist es easy as fuck.
Also im Package Manager ist es total einfach.
Einfach installieren, gut ist.
I'm assuming this is just dragging it into the fonts folder.
Ja, vielleicht geht das.
Nein, okay.
Hätte ich gedacht, vielleicht geht das.
I thought it was going to be as easy...
Wahrscheinlich kann man es rechts anklicken und sagen installieren.
Wenn die mitgedacht haben, die Desktop-Environment-Typen.
Keine Ahnung.
Also ich würde gucken, ob es den Font im Package Manager gibt.
Und ansonsten...
Schau mal im Font-Preview-Fenster oben rechts.
Ah, es ist schon installiert oder was?
Ah ja, okay.
Na dann ist es einfach.
As just dragging it into the folder to be honest.
How to reinstall a font...
...Mint.
UserShare fonts TrueType.
Also ihr wisst ja, ich bin auch ein Manjaro Fan.
Ich habe auch Manjaro, aber Manjaro KDE würde ich nicht verwenden.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall Linux Mint der ganzen Sache vorziehen, wenn ich das verwenden müsste.
Es geht nichts über mein Manjaro i3 WM, aber Mint wäre mir auch auf jeden Fall lieber
als KDE Manjaro.
Ja gut, das ist klar also nicht funktioniert.
Bam!
Jetzt musst du erstmal Font-Config wahrscheinlich neu laden.
Oder dich ausloggen und einloggen oder was auch immer.
Oder geht das auch dynamisch?
Ja, willkommen auf dem LILUX Desktop!
Aber Leute, 2022 wird das Jahr des LILUX Desktops.
Doch, es wird 2022 das Jahr des LILUX Desktops, ich sag's euch.
Allerdings, genau, nicht unter Linux, sondern wahrscheinlich mit WSL und WSLG.
Die Desktop-Entwickler scheißen auf sowas, die haben 20 Jahre Zeit gehabt, was ordentliches
zu entwickeln und kriegen es unter Linux einfach nicht geschissen.
Deswegen sag ich so wie es ist, Linux als tägliches Ding, ich weiß nicht, will ich sagen,
dass das unter Windows gut ist, Windows ist auch Crap, aber zumindest musst du diese 0815
Daily Sachen, musst du dir unter Windows kein Bein ausreißen, um ein aktuelles Game zu starten
oder sowas.
Aber die Dinger, die man gut machen kann unter Linux, die bieten sich ja auch an, unter
Linux zu machen.
Sei es Dinger, Programmieren, irgendwelche Netzwerk-Geschichten oder einfach wenn man
Packages braucht, die man über den Package-Manager nachanzeigen kann, wozu erst den Riesen-Akt
unter Windows machen.
Deswegen sag ich ja, Linux virtualisiert unter Windows ist die bessere Variante als
umgedreht.
Und ich finde sogar besser als Dual-Boot oder sowas.
Was meinst du, wird das Steam Deck für Linux bringen?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher, ob Steam Deck wirklich gut ankommen
wird.
Sollte Steam Deck gut ankommen, dann haben wir vielleicht die Chance, dass sich, wie
heißt der Kram, der Winefork von Proton und dieser Vulcan-Wrapper und was es da nicht
alles gibt, dass das in Zukunft noch besser funktioniert.
Man muss ja sagen, das funktioniert ja eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Aber ganz gut reicht halt für die meisten Games nicht, wenn du einfach so firen-forget
neues Spiel, BÄM!
WinGed, ja, ist ganz okay, aber dadurch, dass Windows jetzt 40 Jahre Wildwuchs hatte,
was Paket-Formate angeht, kann WinGed nie richtig gut funktionieren.
Okay, das scheint schwierig zu sein.
Tja, Drucker ist so ein Ding, entweder stoppest du den Drucker per USB an und es funktioniert
instant alles oder du musst irgendwelche komischen, wie heißen die Dinger unter Ubuntu
beziehungsweise Mint, Non-Free-Repos aktualisieren oder aktivieren oder wie heißt denn der Kram
unter Ubuntu Non-Free und Universe oder irgendwie sowas oder irgendwelche PPAs adden oder sonst
was.
Aber du hast, glaube ich, ganz gute Chancen, dass der Drucker einfach beim Anstecken funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, je nachdem, was für einen Drucker wir haben.
Und wenn es ein Netzwerk-Drucker ist, darfst du dich mit Kubs bisschen rumschlagen.
Das funktioniert, das ist ein Laser, glaube ich.
Vom Namen her würde ich sagen, es ist ein Laserdrucker und das ist tatsächlich relativ
easy.
Das funktioniert meistens einfach.
Zumal Laserdrucker ja in der Regel so mit diesem Standard, wie heißt das, nee nicht
Ghostscript?
Postscript?
Wie heißt die Druckersprache nochmal?
Ghostscript?
Postscript?
Achja, ihr wisst was, das Postscript, ja, damit einfach funktionieren.
Was war denn Ghostscript, wie komme ich jetzt auf Ghostscript?
Ghostscript?
Ah, das ist ein Postscript Interpreter, alles klar.
Ja, Drucken und gut ist.
Ja, das sollte relativ easy funktionieren jetzt.
Ach, Sarex hat das neue E-Mode gefunden, was ich geedit habe.
Linus wird sich jetzt wieder anstellen wahrscheinlich.
Ach, die haben nicht mal die gleichen Drucker, das ist ein bisschen unfair jetzt, aber wenn
die beide gut unterstützt werden, ist wahrscheinlich kein Ding.
Ich schreine nicht so rum, weil was ist denn mit Linus Font-Config eigentlich los hier?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist denn das für eine Schrift?
Comic Sans hätte ich ja noch verstanden, aber was ist denn das?
Cryford ist gets PET, Audi Meton?
find it or I can but it's a real chore you have to like extract it from some
other thing like it's a very giant pain in the butt this just worked as far as I
can tell but until I actually see the page I'm not ready to believe it
connecting printer waiting for printer let's go Andy let's go Andy the lights
flash and crash it's flashing come on CLP talks die lange von den sub good nice next
gogo I was gonna pretty much number six kind of urgent okay was was kommt als
nächstes warum sie ein dokument haben zum blurren ja das ist total beknackt
wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte dass es einfach das ist wichtiger aussieht
challenge number six compress and send all the files on this drive okay das ist
einfach okay also ich würde über kommando zeile machen aber das ist mit
das ist damit tatsächlich ist das ist das ist das ist das ist das ist das ist
warum funktioniert das nicht ich habe keine ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert
das sollte eigentlich funktionieren wahrscheinlich kde crap das sollte
nämlich eigentlich eigentlich ganz gut ach der ist noch am zippen der war
einfach zu schnell ach das war eine temp es war ein temp name bis er fertig
ist mit zippen oder hat es kaputt gemacht
ja gut dann geht es wenigstens vorwärts holy crap andy you know what i think i
just fell for the same thing that i said i wouldn't fall for again
it's here as dot zip it was doing it down here i didn't notice ja gut das ist
halt der nachteil wenn er sind wenn in den riesen monitor hast und dann zwei
millimeter da vorsetzt dann siehst du wenn in die mitte guckt unten rechts nicht
ja das verschwinde dann wieder daran siehst du halt wieder dass das die
mann guck mal es ist ja nicht so als wäre linux des tops irgendwas neues dass
so basic dinger teilweise so unverständlich sind ist ja nicht rein
die schuld des anwenders muss man ja auch mal sagen
archiv name at least it prompts me for what i want to call it i don't see any
kind of progress indicator are you kidding me am i gonna fail to zip a file
deswegen das ist der grund warum ich die drei verwende und eigentlich fast
alles mit terminal mache wenn man sich da merkt wie es funktioniert dann ist es
in der regel relativ easy ich gehe davon aus dass mir 99 prozent der weltbevölkerung
nicht zustimmen werden weil für die ist terminal benutzen ultra hacker mann scheiß
und sie kommen sich vor wie 1985 aber ist es nicht
der font macht mich ja fertig was was wenn er für clips von mir habe ich was
habe ich mal was kopiert und hab gefällt dabei oder was was wenn was wenn hier
für clips von mir ausgetauscht
moment ja das war der chat der chat hat gesagt ich soll das machen
ich war eh fertig und wollte das löschen das ist jetzt das ist jetzt
total aus dem kontext gerissen ich wusste dass es kaputt geht ich wusste
bloß nicht dass das zege mounted war oder direkt das ganze windows mit kaputt
macht aber das egal ich war ich schon fertig ausprobieren
ich dachte da geht nicht da geht wenigstens über die mounds trübe aber
okay
das ist kein fail da kann ich nichts für sway habe ich mir angeguckt für
weyland das letzte mal wo ich mir angeguckt haben konnte konnte man in
zwei weyland nicht mal gescheit wenn aus ordentlichen resize ohne dass es rum
gebackt hat aber auch schon ein bisschen her
das schickst du aber nicht bei e-mail
dann löst und zipps neu dann zipps neue ohne video dauert es ja auch nicht so
lang
und da ist es
wie einer mal desktop ordner verwendet desktop ordner ist so die richtige geschichte die habe ich mir seit 20 jahren abgewöhnt oder erkennt ihr hier irgendwie eine struktur auf meinem desktop desktop der ganze desktop ist ein großer ordner sogar windows lag wenn ich das hier markiere
was ich zum screenshot nehme ich glaube das ist der standard xfce screenshotter den ich da installiert habe das sah mehr oder weniger fast so aus wie bei ihm
ja ja das hängt von der desktop umgebung ab bei mir wäre es ziemlich einfach eine sache und startup laufen zu lassen ich habe nämlich ein startscript was alle sachen ausführt
und am ende i3 startet also im prinzip würde ich einfach eine zweite würde ich einfach in dieses startscript was reinschreiben und es wird gestartet da bräuchte dieses zeug gar nicht
also ich würde das prinzipiell erstmal alles in vlc aufmachen weil da kann ich mir sicher sein es funktioniert irgendwie außer vielleicht hdr
das meiste das meiste funktioniert du hast in vlc bestimmt so ein paar dinger keine ahnung irgendwelche moff files moff container mit komischen formaten oder so ja vielleicht vielleicht geht das nicht einfach im vlc aber das meiste geht
die schrift macht mich immer noch fertig die schrift man ok also unter i3 könnte ich also ich habe mein linux gar nicht laufen also ich könnte hier gar kein shortcut machen unter linux weil
das ist das wo ich mein video aufgenommen habe für youtube so aber ich könnte gar kein screenshot machen weil was mit meinem hintergrundbild los alter ich habe kein desktop unter linux ich reboote mal an der stelle
einfach einfach den ganzen shit wieder aus ich habe ich kann ich könnte gar kein shortcut machen weil ich habe ich habe nix wo ich shortcutte ich könnte einen link machen ich könnte einen sim link machen aber ansonsten wüsste ich nicht jetzt stimmt auch mein desktop wieder ansonsten wüsste ich nicht was ich machen sollte
also ich meine ich kann hier ln-s irgendwas machen oder so das wird funktionieren ich könnte auch hier tuner aufmachen und da irgendwas linken falls das funktioniert keine ahnung nee das ist aber was das brauche ich brauche ich überhaupt nicht
was zum teufel haben wir hier für komische videos drauf wann haben wir das mal drunter gelassen prove that chinese grandparents are more athletic than you was auch immer
a short cut so no i will find another way to do that link to file or directory yes this is a much better way of doing this haha gain for new link bread sim link jetzt which of the command und seile machen fertig
Ich habe nie Shortcuts gemacht.
Ich habe auch keine Shortcuts in Windows gemacht.
Ich kann diese Shift- und Control-Klicks halten,
und dann ein Video aufsteigen.
Das sieht ein wenig seltsam aus.
Das ist ein Link.
Das ist ein grosser Shortcut.
Connect to a network share, this is actually crazy easy because while I am using Samba on my linux
NAS
It's a linux NAS. Andere haben eine Webcam, Linus hat da irgendwie die 5000 Euro Spiegelreflexkamera um und und eine Webcam und eine Webcam
Yeah, so network shared folders SMB
Da hat er Glück gehabt, dass es so easy funktioniert
Ich habe eine Bewerbung von James bekommen. Ich habe keine netten Geräte in meinem Haus jetzt, also hat er gesagt, dass es okay ist, wenn ich ein Folder für Sharing setze.
Ich gehe in die Bedeutung. Oh, Sharing Optionen, probieren wir das. Samba muss installiert werden, die entsprechende Farbe.
Oh ja, oh oh, oh oh, oh oh.
Oh oh oh, oh oh oh.
Wie sagst du das, plus das funktioniert jetzt einfach.
HSG bei 1, danke für den Sub.
Wie das funktioniert jetzt einfach.
Wirklich?
Du kannst das ein bisschen sehen. Ich glaube, das ist es.
In der Ende, das hat mir weniger als 40 Minuten gedauert. Die meisten Zeit war, dass ich ein File warten wollte.
Ich habe das ja des Linux Desktops am Start.
Das ist es's.
Das ist es.
Und das ist es.
Richtig.
Das ist es.
Services.
Und das ist es.
Ja KDE, KDE hat bestimmt auch irgendwie sowas wie Start-up.
Kann das, kann das Discord mittlerweile selbst?
Gibt es irgendwie ein Häkchen in Discord?
Run as Start-up oder sowas, was auch unter Linux funktioniert?
Ich hab Discord nicht automatisch gestartet.
Ich hab eigentlich fast nichts automatisch gestartet.
Das ist bestimmt, das ist bestimmt eh ne Kopierschutzmaßnahme, oder?
Oder warum wird das, nee wobei.
Das ist VLC, VLC juckt sich eigentlich um Kopierschutz nicht.
Ja.
Aber ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das mit VLC einfach funktioniert.
Aber kein Sound.
Ok jetzt ist vorbei, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Predicte ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ok erstmal, erstmal kurz HDR Support selbst programmieren.
Kein Ding, man hat immerhin 15 Minuten Zeit.
Also ich fühle mich ziemlich gut. Anstatt digital mein PDF zu signieren, habe ich all meine möglichen Herausforderungen geschafft.
Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass das Weg hierher zu gehen so unangenehm war wie das, was du gerade gesehen hast.
Ich hatte ein sehr frustrierendes Problem, wo jede Menge Windows Bewegung,
besonders wenn ich anstrengen würde, eine sogar hohe Performance-Game wie FTL zu spielen zu haben, sehr laggig wäre.
Ich hatte ein paar Veränderungen, die mir zu mir suggestiert haben, die vielleicht ein bisschen geholfen haben.
Ich kann es nicht wirklich sagen. Keiner von ihnen hat das Problem voll gesolved.
Ich könnte Distro Op und etwas anderes versuchen, aber ich habe Angst, das zu tun, auch wenn es das Problem lösen würde.
Also kannst du eigentlich von ausgehen, wenn es unter Mint nicht richtig funktioniert, dann ist das irgendwas, wo du woanders auch Probleme hast.
Ich glaube, also einsteigermäßig würde ich sagen, ist die Linux Mint eigentlich eines der besten Dinger.
Auch wenn ich die ganzen Desktop Environments, die es unter Linux gibt, nicht wirklich mag,
außer halt i3 und das ist ja nicht wirklich ein Desktop-Environment, das ist ja einfach nur Fenster im Fullscreen nebeneinander.
Ich bin schon ganz okay.
Ja ja, Chat, Chat, ich glaube euch das. Aber das beste Desktop-Environment, was es für mich gibt, ist immer noch ein Desktop-Environment, was gar nicht vorhanden ist.
Mir reicht das voll und ganz aus, wenn ich einen Shortcut drücke und einfach in den Terminal aufgehe oder einen Browser im Fullscreen
oder ich im Zweifelsfall halt irgendwas anderes starten kann. Ich brauche keine, keinerlei Fenster, Window-Management, wozu?
Und wenn ich wirklich Fenster haben will, kann ich ja immer noch hier in Fenstermodus setzen, ja.
Also, brauche ich nicht.
Deswegen, deswegen mag ich das an i3. i3 hat halt nichts, was einem irgendwie in die Quere kommt.
i3 ist halt ja auch nichts anderes als bisschen, bisschen Tiling-Window-Manager bzw. halt Fenster im Fullscreen, fertig.
Und im Prinzip war es das, mehr brauchst du nicht.
Ja gut, ich habe hier oben noch meine komische Leiste, ja.
Äh, wie das heißt, das ist, das ist ROFI, nennt sich das oder ROFI oder wie auch immer.
Jetzt habe, da, relativ, relativ verbreitet.
Hier 8,4K.
Das sieht richtig Hankermans aus.
Ja, und natürlich, und natürlich T-MAX auch noch am Start, ist ja klar, ne.
Dass man hier, dass man hier erstmal sein ASCII-Quarium laufen lassen kann.
Hier C-Matrix und hier oben den Zug langfahren lassen kann.
Erst dann ist es richtig Hacker-Setup.
Wobei, das geht noch, das geht noch besser.
Aber, äh, jetzt, so ist das, so ist das richtig gut.
So muss das sein.
Oder aber, tatsächlich, was wir auch machen können ist, für die, für die volle, für die volle Hacker-Man-Ladung.
Okay, Chet, Chet, seid ihr, seid ihr eingeloggt, ja.
I'm in, so ist das gut.
Ach, übrigens, Chet, wo wir gerade, wo wir gerade bei guten, guten Linux-Desktops sind.
Also, ich muss ja sagen, der beste Linux-Desktop ist immer noch, ist immer noch der hier.
Also, besser, besser kann es eigentlich nicht werden.
Oder was sagt ihr, also, ich glaube, das ist schon ziemlich, ziemlich weit vorne hier.
So, ich mach mal wieder aus.
Okay.
So, okay, mein, das Video haben wir jetzt, was, was wollen die denn da jetzt noch, HDR,
HDR wollen sie noch machen, okay.
Okay.
Ja.
Das Hit und Miss hat er gut, hat er gut beschrieben.
Ja, so fühlt sich Linux-Desktop schon seit 20 Jahren an.
Ah ja, Windows übrigens zum größten Teil auch.
Ja, gut, machen sie jetzt noch was mit HDR?
Nee, das mit HDR haben sie sich jetzt einfach gespart, oder?
HDR haben sie einfach gespart.
Ah, vergiss, das geht nicht.
Ja, ist ja auch, ist ja auch so richtig.
Es ist genauso wie mit im Browser, im Browser GPU Video Decoding.
Das geht ja mittlerweile halbwegs, aber auch nicht wirklich gut.
Und da haben sie auch ewig für gebraucht.
Äh, kannst du...
Prediction auflöten, meine Prediction?!
Ja, was ist die Prediction?
Prediction auflöten.
ja was ist die prediction die prediction ist ja im prinzip ich hätte auch nicht alles
gewusst
aber ja den unterschied zwischen hartlink und symlink kann ich dir erklären
ok was das mit über einholz muss ich mir erstmal Gedanken machen aber der unterschied zwischen
symlink und hartlink ist hartlink ist quasi auf datalsystem ebene das heißt du kannst
ein hartlink nicht partitionsübergreifend machen und ein symlink ist nichts anderes
kannst du dir vorstellen wie eine textdatei die auf die auf die eigentliche auf den eigentlichen
auf das eigentliche ziel zeigt
dementsprechend wenn du ein symlink löscht passiert nichts wenn du ein hartlink löscht
habe ich keine ahnung was passiert ich würde mal vermuten dann ist die datei weg
weiß das jemand ja ist sie ja hätte ich auch so vermutet jetzt
datei bleibt da ok dann stimmt das nicht was ich gesagt habe zumindest du kannst ein hartlink
nicht partitionsübergreifend machen
ok das ist schlau genug alles klar
haben wir doch das video vom lost angucken zu belphil jetzt weil es ist schon spät leute
schon spät schon spät der ist gehackt als oberpoggers minecraft
er geht nicht mehr ja so wo ist das video vom lost zeige ja das
so leise
wie auch natürlich early access und dann jetzt auch full release ich über 200 stunden
spielzeit gesammelt habe und jetzt einfach im zugedessen mal ein kleines
spielzeit gesammelt
scheiß immer positiv gesinnt waren wahrscheinlich hört enttäuschung darüber was wir auch sagen
schrott aber enttäuschung ist eigentlich eher das haben mit dem spiel was uns vorher
schmackhaft gemacht wurde aufgrund von trailers auch aufgrund von gameplay tatsächlich dass
sich teilweise auch geändert hat ich meine ich muss nur muss nur darüber reden wie es
in der beta war wo leute natürlich große performance probleme hatten die sie jetzt immer noch
besitzen aber es spieltechnisch in der beta warum auch immer möglichkeiten gab die jetzt
im release nicht sind ich weiß nicht ob der brand passen wir auf passen wir auf jetzt
kommt lost erklärt uns versionsverwaltung passen wir auf dass ich das doch erleben darf
ja jetzt jetzt kommt ließ nicht sind ich weiß nicht ob der brand damals an dem weiterentwickelt
wurde irgendwie anders ist normalerweise merkt man das hier zusammen der danke der alles
klar aber hey wir sind im zu jahr 2021 wenn du da draußen immer noch kein englisch kannst
dann ich erkläre es dir ich finde es geil dass mittlerweile sich auch bei den leuten
die damit eigentlich nix am hut haben haben teilweise solche sachen wie branche und merches
rum sprechen ich meine es ist nicht wirklich richtig was er gesagt hat aber die richtung
stimmt das hat unterschiedliche entwicklungsteile des games zusammengefasst werden am schluss
was auch immer macht für mich keinen sinn wir konnten in der sache wie fange ich an
das ding ist komplett ich habe mir keine punkte gesetzt wo ich anfangen das wird einfach
ein das wird das wird ein kompletter clusterfuck das ding ist dafür 2042 ist nicht das bettel
viel erlebnis was sich viele draußen gewünscht haben das ist für mich tatsächlich das ist
so ja ich bin der meinung dass bettel viel und vor allem da ist ja grundsätzlich nur
der geldgeber aktuell in einer in einer krise sind ja wo sind verstehen geblieben branches
ist richtig ob du allerdings alles einfach so aus den branches dann zu einem fertigen
spiel zusammen möchte ich doch mal ganz stark bezweifeln setzen in einer identitätskrise
weil leider muss man das stimmt für mich tatsächlich auch das ding ich bin der meinung
dass bettel viel und vor allem da ist ja grundsätzlich nur der geldgeber aktuell in einer krise setzen
habe ich auch gesagt in video krise das ist das ist echt ein problem man kann nicht alles
nur auf ea schieben klar kannst du dich über kannst du ziemlich gut über ea abflamen und
die haben bestimmt mit ihren entscheidungen auch nicht dazu beigetragen dass das spiel
noch besser wird im schluss am schluss aber letztendlich hat es schon da ist auch mit
verkackt und ich glaube die wissen einfach nicht mehr was ein gutes bettel viel ausmacht
das war nicht gelogen dass sie damals gesagt haben zu bett company 3 sie wissen einfach
gar nicht mehr was ein bett company ausmacht was gut ist die wissen es wirklich nicht
mehr leider muss man sagen dass das game studio da ist was seit 20 jahren plus besteht und
mit dem franchise battlefield unter anderem ja den namen bekommen hat den es lange zeit
auch tragen durfte das studio dass es schafft herausragende muss man sagen zumindest auch
spiel spaß technisch geile multiplayer shooter auf groß scale scale an den start zu bringen
und so wirklich was großartiges vergleichbares zu bettel viel muss man sagen gab es ja auch
nicht die letzten jahre über und gibt es jetzt auch nur einmal sehr vereinzelt sachen
die in die richtung gehen mein heute hast du so was wie squad zum beispiel für die für
die für die hardcore ist aber so was in infanterie action team play realismus sim leute und so
was aber bettel viel ist an sich schon immer noch einzigartig welche bettel fields waren
denn alle von da ist ich würde sagen alle bis auf vielleicht irgendwelche komischen
ableger dies gegeben hat aber alle mainline bettel viel nicht zuletzt bettel viel 3 und
natürlich auch bettel viel vier wie beide teile wie wir wissen oder die leute die es
da mitbekommen haben einen beschissenen start hatten das stimmt auch 42 allerdings dort
halt viel mehr content da war viel mehr bettel viel drin gesteckt ist was man auch gemerkt
habe viel mehr ideen und auch potenzielle entwicklungsfähigkeiten du hast bettel viel
3 und auch bettel viel vier aber vor allem bettel viel drei hast du gestartet und hast
richtig bock auf das game gehabt du warst angepisst von irgendwelchen sinnlosen bugs
du warst auch ich war auch teilweise richtig angepisst teilweise von random suppression
und so was aber bettel viel drei hatte was was bettel viel 2042 bei mir nie ausgelöst
hat du hast dich zwar über das game abgefuckt weil irgendwas verpackt noch nicht richtig
funktioniert hat aber sobald du ausgeschaltet hast wolltest du eine halbe stunde später
wieder spielen das hatte bettel viel 3 auch bettel viel 4 das hat bettel viel 2042 bei
mir nicht hardline nicht ne hardline war ja so ein spin-off von la dies oder so sowas
die dazu geführt haben dass diese games nach einer geraumen zeit von anfangsschwierigkeiten
mit zu den besten titeln im bettel viel franchise gehören und immer noch ja viel von der community
natürlich auch bestätigt wenn die werden heute noch gespielt und wie jetzt mit 2042
mit einem weiteren modern combat shooter was ich viele seit jahren seit ja bettel viel
eins oder davor von mir aus hardline was ja nur ein seiten ableger waren franchise ableger
sich natürlich wieder modern combat shooter wie zuletzt bettel viel gewünscht haben den
sie jetzt mit 2042 ja komm mal muss ich muss ich muss ich mal überlegen die leute haben
richtig gegeiert nach einem bettel viel zu im modern combat setting jetzt kriegen sie
ein nach all den jahren und dann ist das so ein schrott aber es eben nicht das spielerlebnis
ist was wir von bettel für die vier können 128 leute das ist so ein thema was viele auch
ansprechen 128 leute hat natürlich schon immer vorhin ein problem bedeutet performance probleme
die immer noch bestehen 128 leute ich habe übrigens meine zweifel dass sie 128 leute
tatsächlich der kern das performance problem sind ja ich weiß man sieht eindeutig mit
weniger spiele hat man mehr fps aber da muss intern irgendwas ganz kundlich schief laufen
dass es so ein krasser unterschied ist weil man darf nicht vergessen man kann sogar bettel
viel drei mit mods mit 127 spieler spielen und das läuft performance technisch und kleinzeitig
vollkommen in ordnung ich brauche du brauchst halt in so eine nasa server dass es funktioniert
aber kleinzeitig gar kein problem zu dem absoluten clusterfuck größten teils in vielen belangen
was bettel viel 20 und das lag bei bettel viel 3 daran dass bettel viel 3 server 0 multithreaded ist
du brauchst den super krassen nasa single core pc dafür ich habe grundsätzlich gar kein problem
damit muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen das große problem sind momentan einfach die tatsachen dass
wir karten besitzen die nicht darauf ausgelegt sind 128 leute das stimmt bzw. vom design her
nicht wirklich gut funktionieren die ganzen ideen die sie hatten auch mit diesem von a nach b mit
einem fahrzeug funktioniert ja nicht richtig das gameplay wirklich habe ich auch immer video
gesagt funktioniert ja nicht richtig du kannst ja kaum was trocken viel zu selten dann sind
die slots belegt und trotzdem passt immer noch nicht auf den map machen sagt die anfänglichen
probleme mit hava viel 20 42 die zumindest was das hovercraft angeht ein stück weit gepatcht
wurden und jetzt die bolt ja noch ansteht mit ihren 30 millimeter 50 millimeter kanonen auf
irgendwelchen versorgungsfahrzeugen da daherkommen wo ich mich frage was für eine bedeutung hat
überhaupt noch der panzer auf dem schlachtfeld gar keine mehr jeder fährt halt nur mit diesen
transportfahrzeugen ja und das ist viel zu viel vor allem durch die gegend das ist auch viel zu
viel droppt werden bedeutet was das der masse natürlich kannst du nicht ständig fahrzeuge
droppen du bist auch limitiert aber insgesamt gibt es viel zu viele zu kommen du musst wieder
ein paar g style weite strecken laufen oder und jetzt kommst du hast 20 helis die dich umgleichen
interessiert ja keinen was ja redeploy genau du hast 20 20 helis die um dich kreisen und und 20
hovercraft alles mögliche ist viel zu übertrieben strecken laufen oder und jetzt kommt einfach mal
den redeploy button drücken weil es interessiert ja keinen was für kds du hast weil es sieht auch
dass das kommt das habe ich übrigens auch schon öfters gesehen und ich mache das auch selbst
wenn du am arsch der welt bist anstatt zu rennen machst du einfach redeploy aus ist juckt er nicht
scoreboard und so wir müssen nicht darüber also oder ich würde gerne darüber machen das fast
jetzt nicht in höhe von mindestens 25 minuten aus und das ist ja nicht das problem einfach das
battlefield 42 zwar ambitionen hat und die auch hatte mit der entwicklung klar next scale next
gen dies das das problem einfach nur ist dass es komplett und durchdacht wurde ich würde sogar
so weit gehen bin mir gar nicht so hier die hatten vielleicht manche leute irgendwelche
ideen vielleicht auch ambitionen aber da kam nie ein schlüssiges konzept für das game raus das
hat man auch bei den video von tom henderson gesehen hat das ganz gut er aufgeschlüsselt
wann da wie was entschieden wurde und da wurde am anfang so auf die richtung gewechselt da kann
ja gar nichts schlüssiges bei rumkommen dass sachen implementiert wurden die offensichtlich
nicht genug in eigenen reihen getestet wurden ja und jetzt erst durch die große spieleranzahl von
uns die mittlerweile über 70 prozent gesungen ich habe im prinzip im prinzip im prinzip sind
vier beta tester die aber auch noch 70 bis 120 euro dafür bezahlt am beta testen zu dürfen
irgendwo gg werden konnte next next big brain move funktioniert wie sie sich vorgestellt haben und
jetzt kann man wie gesagt sagen ja battlefield 4 und 3 hat er auch da ist hat einfach keine
daily scrums gemacht das wird sein am anfang was battlefield 4 und 3 am anfang hatte waren
gravierende server probleme waren teilweise kleines probleme bugs ja das problem aber es
hat trotzdem noch bock gemacht eigentliche spielen das spiel design und das spielen an sich
kurzmäßig viel spaß gemacht hat und man genau zwei wochen am stück das ist das was ich immer
auch gesagt habe du hast sich zwar abgefuckt über battlefield 3 und battlefield 4 aber wenn
er eine halbe stunde nicht gespielt hat hast du dir gedacht ich könnte jetzt noch mal wieder
eine runde spielen das habe ich bei 2042 nicht auf den rubberbanden server von battlefield 4
trotzdem bei 50 meter geradeaus laufen zu können weil es trotzdem ein geiles erlebnis war und
versteht mich nicht falsch 2042 hat seine momente wenn es mal funktioniert sowohl von
server performance sowohl von klein performance und ich kann ja sagen ich habe wenn es kein clusterfuck auf der map ist
diverse fixes sind so für ein paar frames hier und da bei manchen mehr bei manchen weniger ich habe 1500
euro in die hand genommen was ich hier machen wollte aber passenderweise zu battlefield 2042 dafür
gesorgt hat dass ich einigermaßen stabile gute fps da hat er ein paar prime subs verbraten
kann man ja mal mal 5 davor keine 200 oder so steady das habe ich jetzt auch nicht erwartet aber ich
kann jetzt wenigstens ein bisschen mehr her meiner fähigkeiten und möglichkeiten battlefield sein
und dadurch macht es mehr spaß ich würde niemals dazu aufrufen jetzt für battlefield 2042 seine
technik abzugraben würde nicht eh vor Ort ist ein upgrade zu machen weil die performance
optimierung immer noch weit unten ist und es da immer noch anpassungen bedarf aber es hat seine
momente und es kann auch spaß machen das problem ist nur und da muss man natürlich gucken ob es
aus der eigenen intention entsteht weil ich 20 jahre lang das franchise schon spiele ich bin
ein kind von battlefield ich habe seit sekunde eins die wake island demo von battlefield 1942
damals gespielt demus ja das habe ich tatsächlich nicht gemacht immer in geraume zeit spielen seitdem
habe ich gesuchtet ich habe competitive gespielt über mehrere jahre mehrere titel sowohl online
als auch offline aufladen und ich habe battlefield geliebt in der lande aber allerdings ist es mit
den letzten jahren gerade zuletzt also seitdem hartline halt losging und am battlefield 1 zu
battlefield 5 hat immer eine richtung gegangen hartline aber ganz im ernst hätten wir gewusst wie
in die hose battlefield 2042 geht hätten wir sogar hartline lieber rauf und runter gespielt
nicht zugesagt hat entweder setting oder eben auch die tatsache in welche richtung sich entwickelt
hat und das sieht man jetzt auch wieder 2042 ja es hat sein moment die spaß machen wenn ein paar
leute weg ist es ganz cool aber es hat keine bewandnis mehr und jetzt komme ich noch mal
zurück scoreboard es ist einfach damit beschrieben aber es hat für mich keine bewandnis mehr da
viele leute zu killen weil das ist ja und vielleicht euch im stream kriegt keiner mit
du kannst dich nicht messen mit leute im online shooter das stimmt schon habe ich den redeploy
ja um irgendwo anders spawn habe ich habe ich bei mir im video ja auch gesagt das finde ich
ist auch keine gute entwicklung und alles nur für irgendwie tante bronhilde oder wen auch immer das
dann das game hat einfach keine schlüssige vision nur mit dem wing suit von zahnens runter
zu springen um schneller an den nächsten punkt zu kommen weil du keinen bock hast jetzt wieder
eine minute darüber zu laufen die maps sind bis auf ein maximal zwei diskade kann ich da nennen
ganz cool total meine manifest geht auch schlecht designt und das sage ich als jemand der battlefield
5 vorbettel field 2042 monatelang gespielt hat und dafür fünf hatte schon beschissene maps okay
kann ich nichts zu sagen habe ich kaum gespielt das ist so die sieben maps die wir bekommen haben
sind die maps sehen auch noch hässlich aus in 2042 sowohl in conquest als auch in breakthrough
ich sage ich sage nur hour class leute hour class schlimmste map diese je entworfen haben
modi die wir da haben und ich glaube nicht dass sie das so schnell hinbekommen das kriegen sie
erst hin wenn sie neue maps pushen der content der momentan da ist reicht einfach nicht aus um
langfristig dran zu bleiben das hat einen grund warum viele leute gegangen sind das
liegt nicht nur da 85 prozent ach nee das war new world sorry sorry das war new world 85 prozent
spielerverlust wellfield hat nur 70 prozent oder so aber ganz ehrlich ich kann dir aus meiner
seite aussagen selbst wenn du 130 bis 150 nur in schnitt die nach dem welche map ich habe manchmal
auch mehr kann auf 180 teilweise 200 wenn ich in himmel gucke auf breakaway ja aber selbst wenn
du gute performance hast ist es cooler weil du natürlich die mausflüssiger alles drum und dran
die beste leute besser kills aber ich kann dir aus meiner erfahrung sagen und den über 200
stunden die ich jetzt habe auf den konsolen spielen immer noch 70 prozent der leute ich wüsste
nicht warum der trend großartig anders sein sollte also du hast 70 prozent der spieler
insgesamt auf konsole ja mindestens ja klar das glaube ich nicht also ich glaube nicht dass der
trend so unterschiedlich ist zwischen konsole und pc wir wissen ja beispielsweise auch die
origin zahlen nicht aber ich würde sagen der trend den man da auf steam sieht ist sowohl bei origin
auf beiden konsolen ähnlich immerhin es mag vielleicht es mag vielleicht gerade auf den neuen
konsolen da gibt es tatsächlich nicht so viele games es mag vielleicht nicht so schnell gehen
aber der trend ist auf jeden fall in die gleiche richtung was anderes kann ich mir da beim besten
will nicht vorstellen belegen kann ich nicht weil es gibt hat keine zahlen von den konsolen aber den
besten hinweis den wir haben ist eben vom pc und da geht es rapide nach unten das wird die
konsolen auch betreffen weil man sollte es nicht viele designentscheidungen sind vieles noch
komplett nicht genervt ist hier fehlt noch ein bar viel fehlt noch nerf back sind noch am start ja
und das soll die nächste zeit kommen aber der große das große problem ist einfach was ist ein
normaler prozentualer drop an spielerzahlen nach einem monat das kommt ganz entscheidend auf das
game an ist das ein reines singleplayer spiel dann mag das schon wieder komplett anders aussehen man
müsste sich mal ein vergleichbares multiplayer spiel ansehen also ich kann jetzt zum beispiel
sagen new world best beispiele new world hat es geschafft in sag mal mal ähnlicher zeit 80 85
prozentigen nicht ganz ähnlicher zeit hatten hat einen monat länger zeit einen 85 prozentigen
spieler drop zu haben aber new world ist ja ein fast noch größeres shit fest als battlefield 20
42 halo kann man glaub auch nicht so richtig gut als beispiel für nebenbei das am ehest noch
ankommt bei die kampagne auch enttäuscht hat müssen wir mal gedanken machen müsste sich ja die
call of duty spielzahlen kann man sich leider nicht angucken bei steam statistiken ich kann
nicht sagen was normaler was normaler drop ist aber also 85 prozent bei new world und
irgendwie 70 bis 75 prozent bei battlefield ist bestimmt nicht normal battlefield 3 vergleichen
können wir nicht weil battlefield 3 kam kam am anfang nicht auf steam raus wir wissen es nicht
ja gut cs go play account ist ja im prinzip all time high erst letztens wieder gewesen das kann
man nicht wirklich vergleichen steam cs go aber cs go ist ein gutes beispiel für wie das laufen
kann wie das wie das ganze laufen kann wenn man ein spiel ordentlich supporten und vielleicht
nicht unbedingt in die richtung entwickelt wie es jeder will aber was schon in der richtung was
das im spieler hält ich ich persönlich vermute ja die haben fortnight das ist alles so das kann
man schlecht verkleiden kann schlecht muss man verkleiden also ich das ziel von so einem service
game muss ja eigentlich sein auf lange sicht mehr spieler zu bekommen oder zumindest mal versuchen
dass es ungefähr konstant bleibt als spieler zahlen im freien fall ist glaube ich nichts was
irgendjemand bei einem service game haben will langfristig willst du eher noch mehr leute erreichen
jetzt kommen wir erstmals wird fertig ich sag es wie es ist wir haben zu wenig waffen wir haben
zu wenig viel zu wenig waffen wir haben gar keine maps die infanterie basiert sind damit meine ich
nicht tdm sondern ich mein maps wie battlefied 5 zuletzt wo wir dieses strategische und taktische
es ist aber auch was anderes als bettel für die offensichtlich die haben ja auch spieler
bettelfitt nicht play out wählen konnten und dann maps hatten wo halt nicht irgendwie 15
hovercraft auf einmal dich bumsen zu wenig war die infanterien focus ja was 2042 zu wenig maps zu
wenig waffen haben sollte bei 120 leuten die gefühl dass infanteristen rumlaufen auf der map
haben wir nicht und das kommt irgendwann das erste content update kommt nächstes jahr
februar da soll es ein maximal wenn überhaupt zwei neue maps geben das ist das ist viel zu
langsam und was auch was ich auch ein bisschen bedenklich finde dass sich teilweise leute von
da ist da auf twitter feiern ich kann es natürlich verstehen unter den aktuellen bedingungen ist es
natürlich schon sagen wir eine eine leistung gewesen wir haben uns jetzt auch letztens in
diesem video von tomm händlers angucken leistung gewesen tatsächlich irgendwas spielbares raus
zu bekommen aber sagen wir für das game design muss sich ja wirklich bei da ist keiner auf die
schulter klopfen specialist und ein paar waffen zu den 22 die wir bisher hatten im vergleich zu
weitaus vielen ich hätte 50 waffen mindestens erwartet tatsächlich im zwanzig ja gäbe ich
gäbe ich ihm recht es wäre auch es wäre auch überhaupt kein problem gewesen 50 waffen in
2042 einzubauen ich meine du hast einen modern warfare setting vor allem in der zukunft du kannst
alles einbauen du kannst dir irgendwas ausdecken und einbauen und niemand kann herkommen aber das
gibt es doch so gar nicht du hast quasi kompletten freifahrtschein für maps und für waffen und
dafür gibt es gibt es nichts jetzt du hast alles so schnell freigescheidet du kannst in bot lobbies
die waffen freischalten und hast halt an einem tag alles erreicht gut ob ich habe ja mal zwei
freigeschaltet attachments haben so gut wie keine bedeutung ich habe eine mp9 wo ich vier
verschiedene 2042 ist bettel viel auf ruhig bestellt ja schon so ein bisschen 2042 ist content drin nur
damit content drin ist aber dieser content der drin ist macht größtenteils keinen sinn funktioniert
nicht so wie wir es erwarten ja bietet damit 0.0 das hier weil es sich genauso anfühlt als wäre es
nicht drin das heißt es bietet keine mehr wert und das ist das problem und ich kann ja nur von
mir sprechen aber das ist das problem wo ich aktuell keine langfristigkeit in bettel 2042 sehe
da kämpfe ich das vollkommen recht aber ich bezweifle dass mich eine map so hart kommend hucken wird
dass ich sag ich spiele nur die eine map weil fun fact hier das ist auch so ein ding was ich
nicht verstehe oder so was heißt ich verstehe man kann sich irgendwie schon zusammen rein es ist es
ist das fetteste bettel viel überhaupt da war massig kohle dahinter es waren massig viele
entwickler studios und entwickler dahinter und trotzdem kommt irgendwas raus was zu früheren
zeiten nicht mal als ein drittel game durchgegangen wir also tja du kannst ja die map nicht mal
aussuchen wir haben keine server browser wir haben keine map rotation dem wir zumindest drin bleiben
können und sagen können ok ja natürlich nach diskade kommt breakaway und oder oder dass man
zumindest sagt diese map map selection manifest und manifest kann das von angry jaw habe ich
zum teil geguckt ja aber nicht alles es geht eine stunde oder so die nicht so mag weil danach
kommt die map die ich mag nein gibt es nicht du musst suchen suchen suchen bis du die gefunden hast
es sind so viele aspekte und ich habe darüber schon gesprochen die einfach offen darstellen
dass bettel viel und durchdacht ist dass ich sagen muss und ich bin damit niemanden tagine aber für
noobs ist ja ok das auch das auch aber es ist einfach auch auch selbst dafür ist es undurchdacht
die leute ranzuziehen die vorher vielleicht auch kein benefit gespielt haben um ihre
erfolgserlebnisse zu feiern sich nicht degeneriert irgendwie von irgendwelchen leuten
anscheißen zu lassen weil sie schlecht sind sich selber nicht im scoreboard sehen damit nicht sehen
dass sie schlecht sind und einfach mit ihren nicht dass da nicht nicht dass da jemand gekränkt ist
wenn man ihm sagt es sagt in dem game und sich ihr leben freuen und ganz ehrlich ich freue mich
ja für die weil die leben in ihrer bubble und fühlen sich gut und fühlen sich gewertschätzt
vom spiel aber was ist mit der core community der shooter core community in der core community
vom battlefield auf die scheiß man schlussendlich und jetzt kommt auf die scheiß man und die verarscht
man noch das ist ja das was mich auch wahnsinnig aufregt dass die in dem trailer so sehr auf ich
habe es jetzt schon 500 mal gesagt ich weiß so sehr auf nostalgie und und wir müssen die alten
leute ansprechen gemacht haben vom base jump bis zu der heli geschichte bis zu der jet pg geschichte
bis zu dem dock tech messern dann dem kaspian border fernsehturm da war so viel dabei weil sie
wussten und da könnte ich wetten dass das so war weil sie wussten sie müssen die veteranen
catchen und die dazu bringen geld auszugeben weil diese leute werden ihn reinweise wegrennen
sofort die mussten die mussten gerade diesen spielern erst mal ins ins geld aus der tasche
ziehen zum kauf jebaiten weil die wussten die können sie nicht halten es gab gar keine andere
chance die dazu zu bringen als mit diesem trailer und das nehme ich ihnen wirklich übel fristig
spielen was meinst du denn von den 70 prozent die das game seit dem verlassen haben seit release
im großteil der das game noch spielst und leute wie ich ja das stimmt leute die das franchise seit
lange zeit spielen leute und jetzt kommt ja du hast bestimmt nur nach 15 die das bestimmt auch
nur nach 15 casual bob der einfach ultra lahm ist die sachen alle zu anlocken aber ja zum größten
teil leute die spiele langfristig am leben halten sind nicht nur die ultra mega casuals da brauchst
immer siehst du aber auch schon da brauchst eine hardcore ein hardcore fern kern für das was es
gerade nicht hat aber trotzdem das game spielen möchten weil sie den spaß haben wollen weil sie
wollen dass das game gut ist weil sie wollen das bettelfied wieder ein bettelfied wird so wie es
früher war hat letztens bei mir ein oder das video geschrieben so nach dem motto max ich mag
hier deine videos aber bitte hör doch auf bettel fiel die ganze zeit zu kritisieren da denke ich
mir auch immer warum liegt es an mir dass das spiel scheiße ist oder an da ist bin ich das
problem weil ich ausspreche was kacke ist oder diejenigen den kacke spiel programmiert haben
ich hoffe das passieren wird ist es jetzt soweit dass man bettel fiel 2042 abschreiben kann oder
abschreiben muss ich glaube nicht aber ich sag es wie es ist aus meiner perspektive ja games die
vor acht jahren haben bestimmt gut abgecasht mit bettel fiel da wäre ich mir nicht zu sicher
bettel fiel 2042 hat sich zwar in der ersten woche ziemlich gut verkauft nur minimal schlechter als
bettel fiel drei aber ob das langfristig vor allem es hat auch so viel geld gekostet das
langfristig so das ding ist ich habe so meine zweifel sich auch über zeit entwickelt sind
besser geworden haben sich zu dem entwickelt was sie sind aber ich bin jemand der sagt mit dem
voranschreiten der zeit unseres daseins auf diesem planeten jetzt im jahr 20 21 mag naiv klingen aber
ihr versteht was ich meine erwarte ich dass ich ein spiel bekommen wo ich nicht wieder sechs
monate bis ein jahr warten muss dass ich den content habe vor mir und spielen kann den ich
eigentlich zu du musst das ja auch machen das ist auch das was ich nicht verstehe es gibt ja es
gibt ja die das gerücht oder oder das liegt dass wohl sehr viele das sehr viel das kontent
contents der noch kommen soll eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger fertig oder vor produziert ist
da kann ich mir sogar vorstellen aber die sache ist halt die heute hast du halt nicht in spiel was
rauskommt und die leute spielen das dann zwangsweise weil sonst nix gibt für einen jahr also die
wären blöd wenn das wirklich so ist und die das nicht verließen würden weil die leute rennen ihnen
dann einfach weg die rennen einfach weg also du kannst dir das eigentlich gar nicht erlauben mit
der konkurrenz die du mein du hast drum herum massig konkurrenz du hast die ganzen bettel royale
geschichten von fortnite pupke apex aus dem aus dem eigenen haus du hast war zone für die ganzen
casual multiplayer bettel royale leute dann hast du noch so dinge wie wie heißt das dieses russische
ding war frame oder so was auch total viele spiele du hast ja ziemlich viele alternativen heutzutage
und da kannst du nicht einfach sagen wir bringen das jetzt mal raus und wenn ihr glück habt kriegt
ihr dann den nächsten ja ein bisschen content destiny ja und die wären einfach dumm hätten
sie den content würden die nicht raushauen den wir zu release haben soll um ein argument was
der immer genannt wird leicht zu entkräften von wegen jetzt kommt naja die hauen hat den
neuen content rein um halt ihre microtransaktions fort nach vorne zu pushen machen sie ja auch doch
doch keinen bezahlten content ja 2042 ja okay ich lasse diese skin kacke das einzige was du mit
dem bettel pass bekommst sind skins ja richtig schalten kann es werden keine waffen mehr oder
was immer hinter einer paywall sein wo du für bezahlen muss um sie zu haben wie es da der recht
vierer fall ja das stimmt dass das habe ich auch am anfang ein bisschen den falschen hals bekommen
ja das ist dass das haben sie zumindest so gesagt ob das so kommt mal gucken aber ja das das ist
schon so kaufen muss das um die waffen und die maps auf dem server spielen zu können das war
damals in bennett vieler fall aber aber da muss jetzt einfach was zu sagen natürlich es ist
trotzdem es ist trotzdem dafür gemacht um sachen zählen zu können ich denke euch mal vor ihr habt
einen season pass ihr habt den free season pass es gibt ja einen free season pass und paid season
pass oder irgendwie sowas stelle euch vor ihr habt den free season pass und auf level 15 ist
eine waffe gut die waffe bekommt jeder aber vielleicht machen sie es ja so du kannst erstmal 14 levels
skippen mit pay to win dass du die waffe gleich bekommst jemand anderes bekommt ihr halt vielleicht
ein bisschen später vielleicht ist die waffe sehr gut und dementsprechend ist es ein anreiz
darauf erstmal 14 level zu skippen das ist das erste ist jetzt eine vermutung von mir keine ahnung
ob das so ist aber das ist durchaus eine praxis die ich mir bei den gut vorstellen könnte aber
trotzdem nicht unabhängig unabhängig davon ob alle das kriegen oder nicht selbstverständlich
sorgt es dafür andere also setzt das anreize dafür gerade wenn die leute jetzt angepisst sind dass
es so lange gebraucht hat bis neue waffen kommen sich dann nicht nur den premium battle pass zu
kaufen sondern auch gleich noch für die paar neuen waffen die es gibt die richtig krasse dinger zu
anlocken und das ist schon alles so gemacht für besseres payment klar es ist kein pay to win in
dem sinn dass man zumindest wenn sie das so machen wie sie gesagt haben dass du sowieso so wie war
das wie war das bei bei bei black ops 3 oder so irgendwelche waffen mit besseren stats nur aus
einer aus einer loot box ziehen kann so so wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein insofern in dem
gesichtspunkt hat er schon recht aber trotzdem ist das alles so gemacht und geplant wie sie es jetzt
haben sicherlich dass sie das besser monetarisieren können und wie gesagt ob das mit dem ist es
vor produziert und oder nicht ja gut das weiß ich nicht ob das ob das stimmt und letztendlich sorgt
dieses später tropfen natürlich auch dafür dass sie dass man versucht den leuten langfristig
irgendwie mehr spielzeit zu entlocken und langfristig den leuten mehr spielzeit zu entlocken
führt am ende auch zu mehr geld das ist schon alles so geplant für mehr mehr stonks mehr
monetarisierung mehr bessere vermarktbarkeit und ob es nicht doch irgendwie pay to win geben wird in
irgendeiner weise da wäre ich mir auch mal gar nicht so sicher ich meine die haben gesagt dass
das nicht so ist aber mal ganz im ernst glaubt noch irgendjemand was da irgendigen business
stonks mann von ea so erzählt vielleicht sagen sie hey waffen und maps gibt es für alle aber
attachments es gibt spezielle attachments die nur freigeschaltet werden können mit dem premium
season pass oder über den shop oder was auch immer vielleicht fällt ihnen das nach einem
jahr ein so nach dem motto ach nee haben wir jetzt doch kein bock mehr drauf wir machen jetzt doch
pay to win da stecken wir doch überhaupt nicht drinnen und zutrauen würde ich das denen auf
jeden fall weil es die leute da sind die das nicht wissen da musstest du denn die das sie kaufen
hey und es hat funktioniert und ich fand es echt ganz cool und wenn du es nicht hattest
konntest du halt einfach die maps nicht spielen die auf dem server waren und konntest auch gar
nicht auf den server steuern ganz einfaches thema hast du nicht bezahlt warst du raus das
wird bei 2042 aber nicht sein das heißt jedes update das konnen update kommt im ersten jahr
und das sind vier stück alle drei monate season pass mäßig wird es eine neue map geben und neue
waffen die jeder benutzen kann egal welche version von 2042 haben und jetzt ist das problem aber wie ich
gerade wie ich gerade schon gesagt habe sie haben wir trotzdem durch diese content möglichkeiten
das zu monetisieren warum haben wir nicht von anfang an schon 50 waffen ja das frage ich mich
auch weil es keine monetisierung dafür gibt naja also ich monetisierung ist da sicherlich auch ein
grund für ich gehe mal schlicht und ergreifend davon aus also wenn wir jetzt mal von ausgehen
dass diese alles ist vor produziert vor produziert liegt nicht stimmen das ist warum es das nicht
gibt ist das gleiche problem wie das restliche game warum das restliche game sagt weil es einfach
keine substanz hat weil es es einfach nicht gibt weil man einfach nicht kreativ genug ist weil man
sich einfach nicht genug gedanken dazu gemacht hat weil man einfach gar keine ahnung mehr hat
wie man eigentlich ein ordentliches battlefield baut das wird das eigentlich das eigentlich
problem sein warum es quasi nichts gibt in diesem spiel obwohl da millionen drin versenkt wurden und
und und was weiß ich wie viele hunderte entwickler und studios dran gearbeitet haben weil man weil man
einfach ein ja kein plan war hat was man macht wie am anfang gesagt hat da gäbe ich mir recht da
ist hat keine ahnung mehr was sie treiben als um content zu sein und und er hat sicherlich nicht
dazu beigetragen dass es besser wird können wir haben im ersten jahr den und den content
nachgeschoben ja aber das problem ist ja dass wahrscheinlich bis dahin gar keine leute mehr
da sind die das game spielen ja nicht mehr so viele und dann ist vorbei am anfang haben es
ist ja es ist ja auch nicht so wenn die leute am anfang richtig krass enttäuscht sind von einem
game viele von denen werden das spiel nie wieder installieren die sagen hey game hat mich enttäuscht
gucke ich mir nie wieder an und ich sage es wie es ist ich bin kein spieler und ich bin vergleicht
das immer mit destiny der sich ein game holt das vier wochen spielt dann am ende des content ins
dann drei monate wartet und dann wieder zurück mehr das war ich auch nicht so in diesem das
ich das das mache ich auch nicht ich bin da auch kein typführer gäbe ich dem loss komplett recht
ich will ein game richtig wenn es mir gefällt will ich ein game richtig krass grinden durchgängig
am besten für fünf jahre am stück regelmäßig wenn es gut ist guter bereich ihr kennt das viele
sind darauf eingestellt die kennen sich anders ja ich bin da kein fan von ich auch nicht spiel
rauskommt dass ich das spiel dann habe und dass ich dann content drin haben um das spiel
langfristig spielen zu können und auch einen spaß haben jetzt kommt bis das nächste content
update kommt und jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen ja aber das ist doch dein eigenes problem wenn
du nach zwei wochen schon kein spaß mehr das wäre das wäre so das war so ein typisches youtube
comment ihr seid doch alle selber daran schuld dass ihr kein spaß mehr in dem game habt ich
habe sehr viel spaß das wäre so ein typisches youtube comment ja aber an wen ist das spiel
gerichtet an herbert müller antraten brunhilde in der woche computer spieler spielt und in diesen
zwei wochen in battlefield 2049 4 kills macht und damit level 0,5 in der ersten woche erreicht
ja klar natürlich der bis zu seinem renten alter hat der spaß an battlefield 2042 weil er
wahrscheinlich dann in 20 ja noch zwei waffen freigeschaltet hat die mein gedanke aber hört
mir doch auf wir sind nicht mehr im jahr 1995 wir sind in dem zeitalter und das kann man jetzt
positiv oder negativ sehen wo viele leute zocken als hobby haben wo die gerne mal fünf stunden am
tag vom pc hocken computer spieler spielen ja und battlefield 2042 erlaubt viele möglichkeiten
da draußen um den kontent auch entsprechend freizuschalten muss einfach nur den bingeling
motion sensor mitnehmen und abgeht abgesehen davon von den bot lobbies wo du innerhalb von
einer stunde spätestens alle attachments von einer waffe freibekommt ich glaube ich glaube
das kann man auch ein bisschen das kann man auch ein bisschen mit mit mmos vergleichen es sollte
immer so hardcore content geben der für normalos nicht machbar ist nicht erreichbar ist einfach
dass man was hat auf dass man hinarbeiten kann auch irgendwie dass es noch irgendwie so ein
bisschen was mysteriöses gibt und dass die high end progress leute was zu tun haben es ist ja nicht
umsonst so dass quasi so der der end end end game content bei allen spiel immer hardcore crying die
ist das muss ja so sein letztendlich du kannst ja nicht erwarten dass man 50 prozent der
entwicklungszeit in content steckt in zwei prozent der leute sehen aber trotzdem muss es muss in
irgendeiner art und weise was vorhanden sein und das muss es einfach geben weil die hardcore leute
auch die sind die letztendlich das game auch mal in schweren zeiten eben am leben halten auch das
sind auch die die letztendlich schlagzeilen machen den ich das ist das großartig was was
sei die world first clears oder sowas aber das sind die leute die im kern an spiel ausmachen nicht
tante brunn hilde und tante brunn hilde kannst du wahrscheinlich in der masse mehr cash verdienen
weil es da mehr von gibt aber auch die hardcore fans buttern massig kohle rein wenn es da
irgendwelche sinnvollen transactions gibt und das spiel hat einfach keine richtige fokussierung
ja da hast du da ein bisschen portal da hast du da ein bisschen hazard zone was einfach der
komplette shit schlechthin ist niemand spielt hazard zone spielst du mal denkst du die erste
runde ist ja eigentlich ganz cool das ist fünf runden gespielt so jetzt habe ich schon alles
gesehen ja eigentlich kacke so und portal ist halt vorhanden portal hat paar coole ansätze aber
portal ist auch nicht das was jetzt irgendwie die tausenden zehntausenden leute irgendwie von
rechner treibt oder so warum soll ich battlefield 3 in portal spielen wenn ich einfach battlefield 3
spielen kann mit mehr content und besserem gameplay da gibt es auch überhaupt keinen sinn und dadurch
hat man alles vernachlässigt was eigentlich battlefield ausmachen sollte nämlich das was
links im hauptmenü ist was die unter warfare stehen haben warum ist das nicht da die gleichen
probleme die das game an allen stellen hat keine vision keine leute die plan haben und natürlich
letztendlich auch im nacken diese diese diese dieses dieses drei gesplitterte ding aus portal
und hazard zone und all out warfare ist bestimmt ein produkt davon dass man so oft die errichtung
im game geändert hat in der entwicklung und dass man diese massen an entwickler überhaupt
sinnvoll irgendwie parallel an einem spiel arbeiten lassen kann weil ihr könnt nicht
ich sage es einfach mal 1000 ich habe keine ahnung wie viel wirklich waren müsste ich genau
nachgucken ob es es irgendwo gibt du kannst ja nicht einfach 1000 entwickler nehmen und auf
all out warfare drauf drauf schmeißen sagen macht mal da kommt was gutes raus das funktioniert nicht
du musst die irgendwie sinnvoll aufsplitten weil ab ab einer gewissen anzahl ist geld das einfach
nicht mehr die könnten mit kls auf den mount everest dann hätte vielleicht funktioniert aber
das das klappt nicht das ist das hat bestimmt auch gründe also das bestimmt auch darin begründet
dass es so dieses drei gesplitterte ding gibt in dem game dass man eben die entwickler ordentlich
verteilen konnte und die vielen richtungswechsel und dass viele entwickler eben nicht automatisch
bedeuten ein gutes spiel und vor allem auch nicht automatisch bedeuten viel content sieht man
eindrucksvoll an battlefield 2042 weil das spiel war wahnsinnig teuer hatte krass viele
ressourcen hatte viele entwickler drauf geschmissen dann in der zweiten hälfte noch und es ist nichts
halbes und nichts ganzes und vor allem hat es keine substanz und das hat wenig inhalt ja
den fehlt und das ist meines erachtens neben diesen bugs glitches performance problemen und zu
aussagen wie das ein server browser ein legacy feature ist da frage ich mich ernsthaft welcher
marketing voll depp das da zusammen gekleistert hat diesen blog post waffenblumen der immer noch
herrscht hit rack problematik eigentlich eigentlich dürfte ich mich persönlich über waffenblumen
oder oder spread oder so gar nicht aufregen weil ich feier battlefield 3 mit mit suppression und
random feuer aber ich war auch kein großer fan von suppression in battlefield 3 muss ich dazu
sagen die sache ist nur die und ich finde dass diese diskussion gerade mit random spread und
sowas bis in die falsche richtung geht battlefield 3 ganz im ernst oder alle alle alle alle
battlefields außer battlefield 2042 auf welche distanzen haben die dinger sich dann abgespielt
das war in der regel also wenn man das mal mit battlefield 2042 vergleicht waren die anderen
battlefields eigentlich selbst wenn es long range war höchstens mit range in battlefield 2042
maßstäben und da ist es einfach was ganz anderes wenn deine waffen löcher quasi in die luft
schießen anscheinend gegner zu treffen als in den battlefield 3 wo du halt einfach schlicht
und ergreifend näher dran bist es ist auch einfacher in den bett in den battlefield 3
jemand zu tepp feiern wenn du ihn halt noch siehst in battlefield 2042 tepp feier mal jemand der vom
hochhaus in in in orbital wenn der hinten an der rakete steht und das ist noch nicht mal die größte
distanz auf der map sie tepp feier jemand mit red dot mal vom hochhaus hinten an der rakete
kannst du nicht kannst knicken kannst da bringt ja auch kein tepp feier was du siehst den ja noch
nicht mal richtig du siehst da ok da bewegt sich irgendwie so eine so eine so eine grüne so eine
so ein paar grüne pixel bewegen sich da über eine graue flasche das wird wahrscheinlich den gegner
sein über powert sachen hier und da der größte punkt der mich davon abhält langfristig battlefield
2042 zu spielen und in meinem fall rede ich davon jetzt am tag keine ahnung sechs bis acht stunden
bettelvieh zu zocken kann ich mir aktuell nicht vor ich auch nicht klar gibt es ab und zu mal
ein bisschen streben und alles gut und das wird mir sicher auch mal passieren aber das ist ja das
tragische das spiel hat durchaus seine momente da kann man gar nichts dagegen sagen aber die
moment hat das spiel eigentlich hauptsächlich in in in facetten des spiels wo man es nicht
verschlimmbessert hat wo man eigentlich battlefield battlefield sein lässt wenn man infanterie mäßig
beispielsweise auf orbital in einer in dieser fab in einer fabrikhallen oder was das auch immer
sein soll ich weiß ja bis heute nicht mal was das eigentlich darstellen soll in einem dieser dieser
hangars rumläuft und zehn gegner killt durch durch nachdenken und cooles movement und predicting
wo die gegner herkommen sowas das ist das ist nice da funktioniert das im kern noch aber das
ist halt auch der kern der einfach da ist und battlefield ausmacht den sie halt nicht zerstören
den sie nicht zerstören konnten bis jetzt ich bin froh dass es andere games gibt ich auch zocken
kann ich bin froh dass zum beispiel heute im heutigen tag 7.12 super people in die close
mir persönlich macht halo infinite multiplayer übel spaß hatte das super people ist ein
battle royale game mega gut ist nicht für mich dann und ich bin froh darüber dass ein neues
kommt achtung darf man immer nicht laut sagen aber ich werde mir mit sicherheit auch mal die neue
map in wortel oder da bin ich da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob ich das machen werde immer noch das
gleiche gameplay ja es hat call of duty wahrscheinlich nicht aber wir sind das in in wortel jetzt ich
höre da ganz viel geflame dass es jetzt keine loadouts mehr gibt sondern nur noch normales
looten aus kisten das würde warzone ja deutlich näher an normale battle royale springen als
an warzone vorher aber werde ich halt einfach mal machen weil es mal was anders ist und da
bin ich froh darüber andere titel zu haben weil für mich persönlich battlefield leider nicht die
die langfristigkeit aktuell bietet und battlefield ja wir kennen es battlefield ist ein game wo man
eh immer absehbar sagen kann ok bis da und da hältst ich meine bei den französischen titel mal
weniger das war ja ja ja gut das stimmt schon aber da ist da ist zum größten teil mit dran
schuld gewesen kacke marketing in battlefield 5 dann content abgesägt und in diesem fall
battlefield 2042 haben sie explizit gesagt das wollen sie lange supporten das wollen sie dass
das nicht so wird sie haben halt überhaupt keine richtige grundlage dafür gelegt dass es nicht
so wird krieg oder zweiten weltkrieg das hat viele nicht gehuckt wenn sie drei konstan zwei
jahre spiele überhaupt kein problem kommt wenn man battlefield 4 anschaut sollte es mehr
langfristigkeit bieten können vor allem weil modern combat so viele möglichkeiten bietet ja
scheiße kannst du kannst alles machen dies allein im real du kannst alles machen im modern combat
und sagen ja es ist halt auf deine kleinen anpassungen machen sagen hier ist eine neue
waffe die ist halt neu ja ja die ist angelehnt an der waffe diesem allein schon deswegen zeugt
es von nicht vorhandener kreativität dass es das nicht gibt können kreativität zeit alles
faktoren die damit reinspielen und es halt einfach bitter jetzt irgendein attachment was es im
echten leben nicht hat ja sagt bohmer sind eine neue waffe fertig einfach ist es leute
feiern 64 mannmord muss ich auch mal ausprobieren wahrscheinlich morgen streben so ein zahl wurde
nicht genutzt und ich habe befürchtungen dass es ähnlich wie battlefield 5 sein kann das war
potenziell die ja das zu bringen wie zum beispiel wir haben zu beginn keine maps die im zweiten
weg wie bekannt sind 20 battlefield 5 wir hatten kein oma ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen dass
battlefield 2042 den weg von battlefield 5 gehen wird wenn es sich abzeichnet dass sich die spieler
zahlen nicht erholen oder wenn wer sich abzeichnet dass da keine große kohle zu holen ist dann wird
das den weg von battlefield 5 gehen kein berlin kein stalingrad keine dieser maps die man aus
anderen teilen alten teilen oder auch anderen anderen spielen kennt und bennett hat immer gesagt
ja sie wollen das anders aufziehen aber die leute wollen das die leute wollen die bekannten sachen
dann kam das pacific DLC was ja gepasst hat danach kam nix mehr vielleicht hätten sie idee gehabt
westwestfront ostfront was auch immer an den start zu bringen nordfront südfront obendorf
und hoffen dass wir diese warmwetter kaltwetter front nicht weiterziehen oder schlecht gibst du
pings james riesiges potenzial verballern ja weil das potenzial ist da fied vier gleich
für battlefield auch battlefield 2042 auch zu einem art enten 2.0 sie sagen wir überarbeiten
alles und machen es richtig gut das wird nie passiert ja die werden die entwickler abziehen
und fifa packs lieber entwickeln das bringt mehr geld das stimmt schon jetzt schon spät leute
schon spät schon spät habt ihr warum sagt ihr nichts chat schon spät betke richtig spät hier
massiv spät betke spät ja ja ja es ist nicht bei 11 uhr ja und wer sagt denn das erst ab 11 spät
ist ab 22 uhr ist schon spät
ist mir doch egal ob ich urlaub habe schon spät ist schon spät
und schon spät heißt betke alles klar bis morgen macht's gut zu